the following is a presentation of the
saint louis chess club
the grand chess tour continued in
glorious fashion with the inaugural
super bed rapid and blitz and warsaw
poland players were anxious to showcase
their rapid and blitz skills on the
second leg of the tour in the beautiful
capital city the rapid event quickly
reminded the world that age is only a
number as former world champion
vishwanathan anand route everyone with
near perfect play winning his first five
games and ending the rapid portion with
a decisive lead however the blitz
section was another story with americans
fabiano carawana and lavon aronian
storming towards the top of the field
with stellar blitz play coming within
striking distance of the still leading
anon going into the final day but
despite their valiant efforts they were
all bested by local hero and polish
superstar yong kristoff duda whose
incredible play proved unstoppable in
his pursuit to take the title for his
home country passing veswana fondanan to
win the superbad rapid and blitz poland
with the tour well underway players set
their sights to zagreb the host of the
superbed rapid and blitz croatia the
third leg of the 2022 grand chess tour
coming up next
[Music]
[Music]
welcome everyone to round one of the
grand chess tour here in zagreb we're in
front of the croatian national theater
that's put on brilliant performances
throughout the years we expect brilliant
moves from our players here at the grand
chess tour and to call all of the action
let's go to our studio with yasser miro
and christian
hello everyone it's grand chess tour
time 2022 from zagreb croatia the tour
picks up and we are in studios in saint
louis getting ready to call all the
action on this rapid and blitz event boy
i'm looking forward to it i'm your host
yasser along with nero miro
welcome welcome welcome to st louis
again it's so such a great pleasure to
have you it's been years it's been years
yasa and yeah not only it's my pleasure
to be with you but also when i've heard
now that it's coming up next and i even
imagined it in maurice voice and it
gives me goosebumps
yes it's such a whole honor to be there
and yeah expecting a wonderful event of
course absolutely hello everyone and
welcome to our coverage i must say today
is a very special day i did not know
this it's international chess day so all
over the world people are celebrating
chess and what a wonderful celebration
we have in store mirror tell us about
the roster players what people can
expect to see from today's action uh
well there is a very very anticipated
game i believe
yeah but we will get to this
yeah we'll get to this a bit a little
bit later so we have
magnus carson whom i'm referring to as
the world champion yes though he's only
a wild card in this tournament
uh wesley saw
maximus yellow graph
shock moment yara flingier dominguez are
all participants of the of the
granchester this year exactly and a few
more wildcarders uh well maybe a little
bit less fleshy than magnus but ivan
saric representing croatia
he used to be european champion not an
easy opponent at all vaseline
who needs no introduction the players
are arriving yeah and jordan von forrest
young star from the netherlands
absolutely and what as there you see the
players shaking hands mvl on the right
and what about our format yeah formant
is pretty standard but for those who
perhaps joining branches tour from this
particular event so 10 players around
robins
everyone is playing with everybody
exactly uh rapid game 25 minutes plus 10
seconds increment for blitz it will be
five minutes plus two seconds it's quite
a long blitz by today's standards i have
to admit
uh no draw offers and we do not expect a
lot of them anyway
uh for rapid games that's a little bit
of change right so two points for a win
one for a draw well zero points if you
lose that stays under that but pretty
standard power point card for the
blitzes one for win half point for a
draw yeah yeah so and our schedule it's
a five day schedule
five day schedule three days of rapid
today we will have rapid rounds from one
to three
accordingly three rounds every day yeah
and that's on friday i'll make the same
mistake again
uh whoever wins the rapid tournament
i'll call him uh the winner of the event
forgotten
yeah forgetting that we will have 18
rounds of blitz to follow so quite a
week today yes saturday it's gonna be a
first round robin and then on sunday the
conclusive rounds 10 to 18 which will be
the second round in the same place but
colors reversed
and there as we see our players we have
nepo
at the board and
as we see as we know the challenger
to magnus carlson is he's back in action
and we're very very fortunate as as
always to have christian in studio
very good to see you my friend what do
you have about this roster of players
good morning yasser good morning amiro
and a good morning or good evening or
good afternoon to all the chess fans
around the world watching this
spectacular return of the grand chess
tour we have such an eclectic mix of
player participating but one in
particular that i have my eyes on of
course is the world champion magnus
carlsen let's take a look at where these
players stand in terms of rapid ratings
going into this event and of course we
have the world champion magnus carlsen
as the first rapid ranking in the world
at a whooping
2847 that's just incredible an
incredible score that we have there and
one player that we have in this event
the challenger to the world championship
crown the player that won the candidates
just a month ago that is jan nepomnyashi
coming in fourth seed in the world
rankings at
28.36 and then we have the american
superstar wesley so seventh in the world
at a whopping
27.79 that's just an incredibly high
number and then we also have maxim
vashir lagrav the frenchman with three
names ninth in the world at 27 64. what
an amazing pack these four guys are and
let's take a look at the fifth ranked
that is lanier dominguez 20th in the
world at 27 26. i have to say linear
dominguez definitely deserves to be
higher and he will definitely be looking
to do that in this tournament to up his
rating and then we have mahmed yarov
chakriar from azerbaijan well he's
definitely not happy with his world
ranking standing at 32nd position with
26.99 he is definitely not happy and he
will be looking to bounce in those world
rankings in this tournament and guys we
also have some of our friends in croatia
guys hey how's it going anastasia and
alejandro
hi christian
welcome to zagreb the third leg of the
grand chess tour we are your hosts here
in location i am grand master 100
ramirez here with woman grandmaster
anastasia karlovic
we have huge news the entire playing
hall every player it's buzzing here in
croatia because the news just broke out
magnus carlsen will not be defending his
world championship title it was just
recently announced nastia what are your
feelings i'm absolutely shocked of
course i mean i was about to cry
actually when i learned this news and of
course i was i was emotional and nothing
we couldn't expect those news coming
yesterday we had this fantastic opening
ceremony with the prime minister
participating with the world champion
gary kasparov there uh with magnus
carlsen who was absolutely normal magnus
carson that today we have this news i'm
completely shocked really alejandro what
about you absolutely i think that
despite all of the buzz that magnus had
been saying for over a year we always
thought he would sign those papers i was
actually talking to vesseling to paolo
this morning and he said he was sure
that magnus would participate in the
world championship match that he was
going to sign any moment and we couldn't
be any more wrong absolutely and i made
this interview in madrid and he made
this smile we will see and i thought
this smile means i will play and he did
it to the end so now we have a new world
championship match right absolutely
according to the regulations what is
written in the rules we will have a
world championship match it just won't
involve magnus carlsen we instead will
have this one janne pomnyachi will be
playing but he'll be playing against the
second place of the candidates a surging
ding loren who really started terribly
in the candidates bounced back all the
way to second place solo second place
and he will be the challenger or he will
be one of the participants who will have
to figure out how to call them as jane
pognach will play dingleren for the
world championship title in 2023.
but now we still have the game between
madness carlson and yanipong she's
starting right now at this moment the
first round of grunch's tour is on the
way it's on the west we have the opening
move c4 played guys back to the studio
with this news
thank you anastasia thank you alejandra
what to say absolutely absolutely
stunning uh the end of an era i don't
even know what to say we're going to be
talking about it mural yeah i suspect
over the next five years myself he
played c4 first exactly shocking indeed
uh
but we have pairings for this round one
and i've got to say looking at that
setup between magnus and nepo you
couldn't ask for a juicier opening round
pairing absolutely so the pilot will
play with sherlock graf feathers are
facing saric mamidyarov one forest and
dominguez versus saw uh first and
perhaps the only american derby exactly
representatives of the us
nice and of course these players for
over the next five days are going to be
fighting for lots of money we'll talk
we'll break that down
but in the meanwhile the round is
underway
and there we have it our marquee match
up
uh
beautiful
queen's gambit declined i mean
something everybody can understand these
days and to be honest i don't even think
these players are thinking too much
about this game right now they're just
trying to dissect the news well magnus
knew of course but is he having any
buyer's remorse right now after
announcing it is nepo thinking okay how
am i going to prepare for ding now it's
just an incredible day for chess well
it's also international chess day
exactly wow absolutely it's a lot of
information to digest you know
uh so magnus not accepting exactly what
alejandro said that
i think everybody was the same even
though he was toying with this idea that
i might not play and so on
and everybody literally was saying you
know behind the scenes like yeah he will
accept he will accept yeah he would show
off a little bit it comes as a shock yes
for me it was a
very very uh sad reminder the deja vu i
started to play chess in 1972. stop
bobby fischer didn't play chess for
three years and everybody was so eager
that bobby fischer would play
in 1975 and of course he did not
and it was this feeling of
sponsors leaving the room
on moss
and it being
really really injurious
not just for chess but more specifically
for american chess
so i mean there's going to be a lot of
fallout here and we're going to be
talking about this story
for ages to come and again
for those of you joining us late
magnus carlsen has announced he will not
be defending his his title against nepo
nepo will be playing ding
lehren the number two player from the
candidates which makes us recall the
candidates all that much more
in that big fight for second i still
don't believe it i have to say i still
cannot believe that magnus carlsen will
not defend his title i know mayweather
retired five six times in his career i
just don't believe it until the
contracts are signed between nepo ending
maybe we'll see magnus get back in the
mix now another question that kind of
popped up in my head was what would have
happened if hikaru would have qualified
if he didn't lose with ding in the last
round he would have uh been the
potential challenger for the world
championship crowd so there's so
many stories that we will be breaking
down in the next couple of days and
weeks and years probably to come in the
chess world the chess world just simply
changed forever with this decision
exactly a changing of an era
let's get to the game for just a moment
because magnus and nepo are rehearsing a
very often played
line but to me the move a2 a3
is a new move
knight takes e6 uh it was
such a standard move that i forgot
anything else it was playable and
absolutely his position
you know
i was told he was only played eight
times so we might as well
yeah refer to this one as novelty
nowadays right yeah i was thinking a lot
about it so rare
it's novel yeah what is the um
theoretical uh
decisions here uh christian about this
move a283 why was the world champion
attracted to this movie so i actually
have it in the database only played as
twice and there's two responses to this
one knight to c6 is one of them knight
bd7 is another one i just think that he
wants nepo out of his book he knows nepo
is probably one of the best chess
players uh in terms of preparation right
now on the planet given his residual
knowledge from the world championship
match in november as well as the
candidates earlier this year so he's
definitely well prepared he wants to
take him out of the opening get a slight
advantage and see if he can do something
with that knight to d7 was already
played knight takes e6 f takes c6 this
basically uh just delayed this exchange
knight xc6 followed by fta c6 and asked
black to commit his knight where are you
going to put the knight to c6 or to d7
he decided to put it on d7 and this is
what we have right now i'm going to find
another weight corral this pawn on e4
bishop to g2 this is what magnus is
showing right now i still think he has a
slight advantage nevertheless it's just
simply going to be a game and with good
play nepo should equalize this
all right thank you for that g2 g3 again
uh a very easy move to kind of dismiss
miro i mean i think before this move is
on the board
again
if we were playing blitz
i don't think
i could possibly prevent my hand from
playing bishop to c4
and playing uh
let's attack this pawn but g2 g3
suggests that
magnus wants a long game based on bishop
g2 castles and slowly slowly corralling
this pawn and let's face it if he can do
all of those things two bishops
no complaints yeah absolutely so well
the moment it was played i actually
thought yeah that makes sense the bishop
the bishop is going to be good on g2 but
i wonder if anyone has actually put it
on i do
and by the way uh jan
who plays very quickly anyway just full
stop
has played rook c8
all a tempo as if to say
yeah i looked at this too uh rook c8 by
the way wouldn't have necessarily been
the first move that came into my mind
maybe the move actually that was
displayed knight c5 because i would be
thinking to myself
okay my compensation has to be
that i've got to do something with my
knights and i better do it quickly and
that was exactly magnus's trick if you
do start with knight to c5 after bishop
to e3 it does seem like that gives white
quite a significant advantage i'm 900
percent sure still about the nuances but
it does seem like castle long castle
that is comes with quite an impact in
that position i see so the rook c8 was
this
wonderful delay good morning want to see
bishop g2
first yes
commit your bishop now knight to c5 so
that knight d3 comes with great impact
because you cannot exchange bishop takes
d3 anymore i got it but then those
little nuances mirror that make all the
difference in the world what other games
have you been keeping your eye on and
we start our first round
you know quite an interesting game
between uh dominguez and wesley saw okay
because at first i was like did so
really fell into some opening trap which
i'm not aware of but
uh mostly basing my guess on the time he
spent it's apparently some new
preparation from very nicely so
everybody is playing the anti berlin if
i can call the rookie one move the ante
berlin
and unfortunately the variations
that i've seen
tend to be so dry yeah absolutely but
this bishop of full move at least it
does have some idea right so he's ready
to sacrifice the pawn and nowadays they
are no longer taking it and so on and so
on yeah i'm not no big expert on this
one yeah but knight c3 bishop takes d4
knight d5 and
somehow i have actually seen this before
not that i've actually studied it it's
not my job these days to have to study
the openings like yeah i'm not sure
about this c6 move yeah so that that's
exactly what i was talking about so
these used to be if i'm not mistaken d6
is the automatic yeah c6 yes okay one of
the things i do have to say about these
two guys
especially i've called the championships
and so many grand chester events
lanier and wesley are really
opening specialists i mean they it's so
whoa whoa whoa whoa
queen f6 absolutely that's why
it is a little bit interesting i have no
question about it rook d1 look at
well the thing is queen to f6 is kind of
forced right because if you do take on
c8 first there is this queen to b4 move
the bishop is not protected and if you
have to go c5 and then loosen up the
light squares queen takes b7 comes and i
think you're in trouble i've got uh my
my pawn back and uh
dividends yeah with division so queen f6
which still
begs the question can i go queen check
and queen takes b7
you're going to go c5 queen takes f4 and
right you probably cannot take well you
cannot take on eight because you made it
it's mate yes
oops and then look to b8 if you try to
defend the f2 pawn exactly
well defending the f2 pawn might be like
kind of hard like right give it up
give it up i'm going to take it whether
you like it or not okay so we
we do have queen f6
rook d one yeah now he's invited to take
on f4 right exactly the invitation is uh
it comes
it comes with no money back guarantee
you did gunny seven we we leave the
tournament
it surprises me that wesley is actually
thinking for so long because we actually
have seen this game before it's a game
between blanqvist and nesterov and i'm
seeing dominguez's time 27 minutes he's
definitely aware of what happened in
that game now bishop to b6 is one of
them one of the moves bishop takes f2
was actually the choice of nesterov in
that one take on f2 and g5 this does
seem a little bit loose for uh black
we're probably going to head into an
endgame and then my king on f2 is
actually not going to be a bad piece at
all instead of that he decided to go
bishop to c5 much more of a natural
approach but after rook takes d7 look
you were mentioning two bishops i have
control of the open files up to this
point it does seem like white got a
slight edge out of the opening what do
you guys think oh very very clear to me
and
by the way there's a very uninvited
guest in the middle of the board they're
rook d7 i mean i get worried when i see
those uh uninvited guests and there you
see a screenshot of the magnus carlsen
versus a nepo game but uh we're going to
keep our eyes on this one bishop c5
not a novel move right that's still
standard stuff but rook takes d7 no i
think that exactly what they said so
there was only one game which reached
this position was probably bishop f2 so
apparently it is a new move how good it
is that's that's the other way i
understood from uh bishop b6 had been
dropped
as
bishop f2 looks like a very decent
bailout when you think about it but then
if you end up playing after bishop f2
king f2 g5
as
takes d7
any ending that queen f4 business and
white's king on f2 is looking
perfect like
not only do i take this bond but
once i play this this the whole black
structure looks pretty
pretty pathetic okay we'll keep an eye
on this one let's switch back to
what we will call our marquee match-up
between magnus
and
nepo because
again i think some
very awkward and difficult decisions for
both players are being answered very
quickly
it's almost as if
this very rare move a2 a3
was anticipated i i don't even know how
to say it but
look at him go
full b4
i'll i'll tell you what it is just uh
ridiculously well prepared
for the last year year and a half he has
mightily impressed with his opening
preparation he's just ridiculously good
well one of the reasons why magnus has
complained
about defending his world championship
title is how much energy
he has poured into this uh
matches here is the lifetime in rapid
chest don't forget i mean they've played
a lot of blitz they've played a lot of
classical chess but 24 wins to 11
i'm gonna say that's pretty dominating
performance well it is but at the same
time winning 11 games against magnus
carson doesn't matter the format it's
already
by the way 34 draws that's a lot of
draws these guys could write
write
books just based on their rapid chess
and there you see magnus kind of
intimating
like
man
he's fallen right into my preparation
and let me ask you mero has he has uh
nepo
walked into magnus preparation how would
you evaluate
this uh circumstance before well
if you move the night i can pretty much
suggest knight takes easy yeah
and then we we we perhaps have to
discuss a little bit this opposite color
bishop's ending yeah like yeah you know
how black does it exactly
right you can trade later perhaps trades
on c1 yeah trade one time yeah
okay fair enough and then i guess b
seven the guy is not very happy and i
probably will have to take the knight
otherwise knight g5 yeah so i'll have to
take i'll have to go b6 and pray i'm
surviving
and it's not given even though it's an
equal pawns you know opposite-colored
bishops but with the rooks on the board
it's always about you know activity
structure it's very important right
everything favors void remember magnus
making an interview once where
he said something as simple as like
well
it's a two
results uh situation so it was a
successful opening
because i'm the one with the two results
i either win or i draw for nepo that's
not exactly what he bargained for when
he sat down to play uh his first black
game against magnus so if it does go
this way i have to say that for magnus
he'll be doing what magnus does best it
is going great exactly that variation so
it is going in knight takes c1 is on the
board and if it takes on c1 we expect
knight takes e4 at one point to come
there's no reason why you wouldn't
exchange those knights right as black so
i think we're going straight into that
line and uh question for you uh
christian how
what's the evol i think napo is
extremely happy with uh the result of
the opening oh you do yes because the
eval is even steel
it's even stephen okay sure you have
some weaknesses that you have to tend to
especially that pawn on h7 you have to
lose another 10p to go h6 but once you
manage to do that there is absolutely no
pull for white and i think nepo is
generally used to more or less handle
these type of positions i don't think
he's going to have any problems drawing
this one
no problem no i i don't think so i don't
see it well the material is too limited
and napo in general i i don't think he's
afraid of these type of imbalances
well i have to tell you i've seen magnus
draw blood from stone
yeah and maybe even smaller advantages
than this one so we
they are
miro going right down our
yellow brick road we do expect 95 bishop
e4 b6 as you suggested
and how severe it is or not well we'll
be about to find out
for me however
i'm seeing a lot of technical
uh chess ahead of us let's see what
we've got in some of our other games
we're going to walk around we're going
to take a look at the game between shaq
and
jordan van forest looks like a very
orthodox queen's gambit declined
minority attack
well there is bishop takes f3
so shaq will have to to be aware of that
let's continue our walk around ooh
this is interesting
these days the bononi and kings indians
are kind of rare guests
this looks like a
yeah
i was keeping an eye on this one it's
not a true bernoni in fact because e3
yeah he started with e3 okay it was a
banoni temple down basically
no seriously and they say if if a bononi
is minus one pawn how about if you get
an extra typo is it still minus a pawn
or is it minus uh a quarter of a pond
yeah it is still a banana essentially
essentially it's still a banoni i don't
think black
should be happy very happy about his
position but but yeah who knows but this
could have been everything this could
have been a king's indian this could
have been a groomfeld
it started off from a grunfeld probably
perspective but then topalov played this
move e3
inviting uh potentially uh king's indian
setup with d6 or benoni exactly what mvl
chose to do now we've seen we know mvl
is a grunfeld expert right but recently
he more or less stopped playing the
grunfeld as much he started
experimenting with other ideas uh this
love the neem so and so on but right now
we're seeing him going back to his roots
especially in a rapid time format
because this is what he remembers the
best this is what he spent his entire
career uh analyzing the groomfeld that
is and this is what we're seeing from
him right now and i have to say
vesseling has not been as active right
so you want to look at that when you're
getting ready for this type of matches
as well as mvl uh i'm saying so you're
looking at topology you know that he
hasn't played as many games in uh this
last year and you're trying to take
advantage of that
but now having said all of that what
was intriguing for me was during the
years that
vessel in was the world champion
he was one of the very few players who
liked to play absolutely
like uh he
he would challenge his opponent in these
fierce theoretical battles where people
would say hey let's not go there so it's
interesting intriguing for me that mvl
says oh i'll play the bononi against the
benoni expert um that's quite the
challenge and by the way we just saw
e d takes e6 by black
which is
not the bononi
that we're all so used to seeing i
understand that uh vessel and's idea is
to
immediately to pounce on this open pawn
and i suspect
especially thanks to this move knight h5
that black's counter play is all based
on you know you can take the pawn but
only players kind of
oh knight d5 excuse me yeah i'm not sure
about it i'm not sure about clean up but
only players are kind of happy like when
they lose their weakness right yeah but
i wanted this correction yeah that i
wanted to put the knight on f4 and i
didn't perhaps what he's trying to take
advantage of is the fact that you have
those two bishops on the e file and then
i can focus on attacking the e4 pawn
before you uh set up your defense with
rook to e1 so maybe bishop to b7 you go
rook to d1 and then i go back knight to
f6 you also mentioned the knight on h5
is quite badly placed so i might as well
try to return it makes a lot of sense
black would be very happy of course to
trade his backward pawn on d6 for this
nicely centralized pawn on e4 okay we'll
definitely keep an eye on that game and
finally
we get to ali reza farouja
and
the local hero
and
wow
they just
kind of blitz their way through i don't
this looks like one of those um
yeah that's untie what's anti-sicilian
or whatever
to me it looked like anti-seize i'm
sorry what swesnik of sicilian right
when you want to avoid
those big theoretical duels well i must
say this also isn't a game that really
is promising uh
our viewers
that much as it looks uh very sterile at
the moment and so guess what we're right
back to where we we started the whole
day and that is from the magnus car not
your v6 move by the way which i thought
was very decent uh once again bishop b2
bishop b2
this is
this might be
this might be an immediate draw right so
this might be i wanted to come up with a
brave conclusion that might be
i'm glad you made the trip
uh why
if i may ask rook b uh then i take on a3
yeah
so that on a future rook b3 the bishop
has to chase it to c1 and then i trapped
the bishop you're being tricky okay
let's go age six let's say i don't
believe you
oh did i miss something
no you didn't yes no you did i think you
didn't you're a cheeky guy you're
already freaking it it's such moments
it's good morning saint louis
whenever we hang a bishop especially in
bishops of opposite color positions yeah
yeah one question so you
got everything you wanted right
even here i think i have rook to b8 and
that should probably equalize
rook to b8 even here even here i mean
yeah about that with a heavy heart so
you know
takes a three i wouldn't be so sure
about that oh you're taking this ah i'm
here
welcome to welcome to the club welcome
so it's like one of those things when
when uh
when we're on a roll
especially alejandro when he's here sort
of like christian becomes you know
the the go-to uh lamb you know we just
kind of lead him to a slaughter but he
what what what christian was mentioned
let me activate my little friend right
here
turning on the engine
and when he does that too by the way
it's a kind of a challenge it's man
versus machine before we know it um
yeah i suspect we are really close to
that
almost almost certain equality
but it may require
another precise uh move or two by the
way
magnus also has an alternative at this
exact moment he after bishop b2 he
doesn't have to go
he could sidestep and go rook check
followed by a
four
yeah i must say that makes less
less of a
a powerful impression
let's say king cc7 a4 and perhaps
absolutely
the only thing to discuss seriously is
it the draw of the rook d8 because h6 i
think like it's your wars i mean rook d2
and some checks and we play on yeah yeah
yeah but if rook by the way b1 rook b1
oh so he enters this
exactly rookie one bishop takes a3 box
so maybe this king to c7 is just a
really bad move well again because
magnus is slow playing this exact moment
i suspect he's also thinking of rook b3
it was played
or yes rook b3 inclusive and then
cultures okay yeah the first thing i saw
was that oh that's a nice idea magnus
wants after the move bishop c1 to play
f4
to snare the bishop
that i think that bishop
does escape
but it would be a kind of a funny
thing to walk all the way you walk all
the way to trap the bishop did not
happen after bishop c1 we have bishop b7
okay so let's try the right side let's
go to e67
to e7 yes i mean king to c7 does seem to
be quite offbeat let's go to esa yeah
but then perhaps rook c3 is the whole
point of including rook b3
exactly two bishop to d2
i give a check i go to f6 mostly
then i go b5 and i make a pretense yeah
well perhaps no perhaps no but now i
have bishop a5 right yeah bishop goes to
a5 and d7 b6 and it's just
it would be so solid
it's gone whatever i had yeah
and it was rather fleeting too he played
k7 so i think maybe we're going straight
into that line
i see
because if you allow me to go root d8 i
i think this is over right i mean
there's nothing you can ask for often
no for sure uh christian uh any of the
other games uh caught your eye because
again i see this as i was looking at
maybe you guys can jump to that one at
the game between mama dyarov and van
forest because we're seeing indeed some
imbalances in that one as well okay and
also some discrepancy in terms of their
time situation 17 minutes for mom and
dad of only 13 minutes for a van forest
but definitely a very intriguing
position with a lot of imbalances check
that out right i've got it on my screen
and
knight c4
well
i would put it this way that's a very in
your face kind of a challenging move i
basically am saying
uh i'm
let me kill your minority attack once i
play b5 with my knight sitting firmly on
c4 there's no attack by the way uh let
me just throw your curveball and nice
but at the same time by allowing this
capture you do give white
suddenly this released um
central uh pawn duo
when you look at all of these pawns
kind of checkers light you say well that
bishop on e6 does have the potential of
becoming a passive
piece
a5 mixes it up and
yeah i think what he's what he's doing
is actually very clever i mean a5 and
try to try to you know somehow to loosen
a bit the queen side because yeah
white looks very very good in the center
but he needs a couple of tempe to build
the position up so i would not mind like
playing f3 bishop f2 doing it slowly you
know that's exactly what black is trying
to avoid yeah at first i thought that
shaq was going to do something of this
nature with the idea that he would
obscure an exchange but then it occurred
to me that even if you win the exchange
and i have the position with b4
i'll have a
four versus one majority yeah yes
maybe that's not so good well that's
actually very rare but you can say i
have four pawns versus one you're right
three versus one is fine yeah that's
four
and it sounds like one too many two
bishops d7 yeah now if the rook goes
then b5 he reconnects the the the pawn
mass so perhaps your knight c3 i don't
know if it's valid here if it's possible
i don't know i see a check that might
disturb this whole idea of winning the
exchange back
but having said that um
i i think so maybe
well
i feel i'm on the edge of just age four
no no you are making short moves yes age
five is playing ah there is one target
on the board that we did not talk about
t5 and h6 huh yeah
mate right uh e5 bishop f6 rook h6
here you have let's go yeah right that's
that that that's how we work uh these
things
i was teasing uh
gregory kaidonov at the closing ceremony
of the seniors he's basically spent a
generation of american players teaching
them to control the center
develop their pieces to active squares
and protect the king
once he's in the competition he leaves
all of his pieces on the first row moves
his knight away from the king and goes
for checkmate
like what have you been teaching the
american youth
uh rook h5 would you be intimidated i
mean honestly you're attacking with a
single rook come on
okay no no no no no that is not true
it's not true i'm starting to see some
very intriguing lines okay
knight to f4 this knight is coming into
play very very
quickly sorry not knight to f4 e5 first
and then knight to f4 okay get the
bishop back now that adds a defender to
your position so that helps you a little
bit as well nevertheless after knight to
e4 uh for example you go try to go c3
check this line out rook takes h6
followed by knight to d5 knight to f6
i'm starting to see some checkmates you
have to take drastic measures with
bishop to a4 but let's not forget van
forest has to calculate all of these
lines and we know this is the typical
position that uh mamadiarov really loves
to play and engage with and this is most
likely what he's headed towards b5 was
his choice he's trying to develop his
initiative as fast as possible we're
going to uh see a slaughter fest right
now after e5 f4 f5 black is going to try
to do his thing on the queen side white
is going to try to deliver the checkmate
on the king side this one is going to
have a very fun finale guys and what's
happening in the magnus vs nepal game
pretty much nothing the bishop is on b6
finally defending everything the rook is
on d4 there's no way for you to
penetrate on the seventh rank
unfortunately i don't have any
weaknesses as black this one is over
pretty much we're going to see a shake
of hands very soon and let's take a look
at the cameras let's see if the players
are feeling that way as well
and they're
hard to see the clock times
17 minutes for nepo 12 minutes for
magnus
and
king f6 is an indication
we don't want to see king h5 king g6
charging up the board and that's what
magnus is going for right and uh well
do we
take the bull by the horns and play g6
yeah g6 is always a tricky one right
because you're putting the pawn on the
same color as the bishop potentially
giving white another weakness to work
with exactly
i i think you're just waiting for the
king to go to h5
and saying i can live with you there
well what you would like therefore then
as black is to make uh the fantastic
move rook f2
uh just so you can
challenge the rook so something like
rook f1
king h5
rook f1 but okay look i'll give you
everything you want what what's your
next
move after you put the king to h5 i'll
stay on d4 let's just stay on d4 and see
whether you have any active plans uh
stay on d with the rook on d4 so let's
say i go rook d6 rook d4 i'm just
wasting time at this so if i
give you a rook f8 check to c8 i go rook
d8
oh yeah so that's once you go to c8
so once i go to c8 i go rook d rook d8
and that's a full you just stop me at
the game you still have rook to c6 i'm
not sure if this helps you i i don't
think bishop 5 is a threat because i
have all these ideas of h5 okay um and
not only that i think g6 is absolutely a
legit move so maybe at some point it's
time to go g6 yeah g6 h5 and
again magnus will continue his squeezing
python-like technique
um
rook c5 okay let me just refresh my
board for just a moment yeah we've got i
think we're just saying a repetition
guys rook to b1 that's an invitation to
a draw
ooh even king well excuse me the rook is
already on c5 sorry
no worries let's see if he goes to v2
and follows it up or if he tries
some more one of the things uh miro
obviously you were watching the
candidates tournament as closely as we
were here in st louis one of the things
that was very impressive was that uh
nepo went through the entire case we're
seeing a repetition guys undefeated
and he was almost impervious it was oops
he looked up to make sure that they've
made a three-move repetition
and a
friendly start friendly stuff yeah
a draw our first result in this zagreb
grand chest or event as the world
champion
didn't really make
an impression against nepo nepo just
held i think very comfortably i think
the biggest impression he could
potentially make today was within
already
with his announcement
yeah and with though
again for those who are joining us late
uh happy
international chess day everyone
came the shocking news that magnus will
step down he will not defend his title
against
nepo and instead i believe ding lyrin
will be invited to replace our retiring
world champions keeping this particular
much less let's be accurate right
but quite
the legacy
being stopped here he had won five world
championship matches
uh going into what we thought would be a
sixth
yeah absolutely and
uh i remember like casting the
candidates for one of the youtube
channels and at some point of inevitably
comes you know that the the question who
would be the voice exchanger
the challenger who potentially can beat
martin scarless and our commentator they
were grand masters i
uh our answer was nobody seriously yeah
you mean magnus in perfect form we still
would believe i mean right cannot be
cannot be dethroned right
here in saint louis we're all pushing
for the americans nakamura and fabi and
for the first half at least fabi was
actually
doing a very decent job absolutely
forcing um
nepo
to play very successfully which he did
yeah
yeah right he created a monster i just
have in front of me
uh the game of farouza
and ivan sarich and also just feels like
once again uh rook and pawn name games
uh all right companion games are drawn
and this one yeah that
certainly uh feels
like that's going to be the case uh
lanier wesley so lanier when we left it
we actually thought that uh
well wesley has always only managed to
bail out quite successfully i want to
say
he's so successful
so there was something wrong with rook
takes b7
i'm assuming
rook to the first rank was
no
i thought knight d6 for whatever reason
but bishop d6 comes with a check i
thought knight d6 and you can't take
because queen f2 blah blah blah but yeah
i suppose it had i mean we'll let the
theoretician sort it all out for us but
i thought rook d1 might have been in any
case uh lanier was happy to say hey i
have the two bishops and oh by the way
don't forget that there's still some
tactical issues maybe you have to answer
guys we have to go to this game between
mommy the arrow and van forest is just
explosing uh it it's too much fun now
the problem with mamedyaro's position is
that he heard he heard pretty badly
right now he's actually completely lost
now the reason why that's the case is
that we are looking at this variation
with e5 and then knight to f4 and now
you get to put the knight on d5 if black
tries to stop you with the move queen to
c6 d5 comes on the board and i just
simply have too much of a pawn storm on
in the center as well as on the king
side e6 is going to follow up knight to
g6 everything is very close to your king
you're in trouble now what he did was
went the other way and after knight to
c3 queen to c6 the problem is you're not
going to get the same setup if you go e5
bishop to f8 now knight to d5 is not
possible because the queen is protecting
that square and if you do go d5 queen to
g6 this is a huge square for my position
if i manage to uh exchange the queens
your rook first of all is going to be in
deep trouble but or so this knight on c3
is very badly placed because b4 is going
to attack it c3 is going to come down
the board you're lost on the queen side
this is what we're seeing right now
queen to c7 and it does seem like
mamedyarov is taking a very long thing
right now
from 12 minutes to only eight minutes
and realizing that he might be just
simply lost busted right now because b4
is coming if you put the knight on d5
first there's no more e5 because now the
knight on d5 is hanging so there's no
way to develop your attack as white big
trouble for chakriar right now after
queen to c6 and dropping down to his
last eight minutes let's take a look at
the camera and see his facial expression
let's see whether he's concerned or
whether he shows
his opponent that he's concerned
he looks pretty focused he does
i think that is a look uh of concern
and jordan on the contrary looks also
rather confident i mean i think he
realizes that he uh
missed that yeah
well honestly you know sometimes when we
especially when we look at definition we
forget that players do not see that of
course them it could be like not black
is winning but just a very sharp
position
yeah perhaps i went no
razor sharp maybe it was a better move
but yeah we are seeing now let's say i
see you on my screen yeah mommy diary
would declare dead lost but once again
dead lost with equal material both full
of pieces no it's not
that what was extraordinary to me was
these ideas that the knight once it
lands on d5 apparently once it lands on
f4 it's shockingly
going uh making f6 and causing
a lot of
aggravation in black's camp and it was
such a
remarkable difference
at first sight you know if somebody
suggested to you you know i want to play
knight c3 so i can play knight d5 you
might think to yourself that's quite
reasonable yeah i understand your
motivation and it turns out it makes all
the difference in the world
and suddenly your center
pushes in the center don't hit their
targets and that move queen g6
uh
will uh and this is what concerns me
before
this is what concerns me for white as
well because uh jordan played queen to
c6 uh instantaneously so he kind of
understood or at least signaled that he
understood the position and the
requirements of the position knight to
d5 is on the board right now exactly and
i like bishop to f8 came immediately
yeah i like that move bishop f8 a lot
you know kind of just sidestepping e5
bishop g3 also came very quickly it's
like shaq is sitting there thinking
well i'll get my bishop to e5 i'm not
sure what it necessarily does once it
arrives on this
exalted square indicates the square for
the rook as well so now queen g6 at
least uh the rook won't be trapped yeah
you get to play rook h4 on a good day
all nighter four yeah knight the four is
there anyway exactly yeah so let's just
say rook b7 rook cc
he wants to push his pawns
understandable and again pursuing the
attack with bishop e5 it all looks
very charming but that's not a threat
yeah yeah
it takes a while to even
acknowledge there is some threat by the
way rook c8 on the board
my bad um
you know i it was first of all it was in
his match with nepo that magnus himself
proved that a bishop on f8 is a
wonderful defender of the black king but
i remember anatoly karpov doing in this
in a zaitsev
like for a better part of 10 years you
know he put his bishop on f8 and
there was only one guy gary casparov i
really proved you know it wasn't enough
everybody else uh fell short of the goal
uh miro yeah yeah but that's really
that's a very typical setup so you just
put the push up on f8 and it's very very
hard to get to the king exactly
right on the board and by the way
another player that's taking over is mvl
versus against desolate yes
that was the binoni
how do we even call it the delayed
bononi yeah something lonely
well again ironically
to
our
simple eyes
board full of pieces like you said miro
it wouldn't cross my mind that the
evaluation is
terrible
it is terrible look at those pawns
rolling down the board rook c3 a4
push him baby let's get those guys let's
get those he's not very subtle he's not
subtle at all controversial opinion it's
very easy position to play for why
because you know you're not stopping
this you're just throwing everything at
the king if it works it works if it
doesn't okay okay next time
let's jump to that mvl game that you
were mentioning because uh things have
gotten worse and worse
for vessels what happened so he decided
well we left it we left back to
13 yeah no even earlier even he couldn't
see one yeah he he gave up his beautiful
dark squared bishop for a lousy pawn can
you imagine that well and porn tend to
be milk so lousy right and then he had
to sacrifice an exchange for a dominant
knight
and vessel in it is one of those players
in the mold of bobby fischer who just
prized the two bishops
if you look for example in his
world championship match against
vladimir kramnik and elista
one of his spectacular victories was
with
the two bishops
and he he proved it but
i don't think this is one of those great
moments because
this bishop
is actually about ready to get booted
and
this night is not impressing and by the
way that's a second exchange well that's
not clear to me i mean it fell apart so
quickly exactly
so well
the moment the pawn was lost or
sacrificed i believe it was sacrificed
it was a very strange decision here i
mean everybody plays queen d2 more or
less there's not a lot of
thinking about it he did end up
capturing okay you see one rook two the
one yeah and then black there goes the
ball captures the pawn but yeah but
still i don't believe that it's like
white has to be like what's the
evaluation now like minus four or
something in five moves no no sometimes
yeah you just have to shape up and play
this position pawn down yeah and he was
trying to prove that okay it was
conscious decision i had everything
under control and then here goes the
exchange sacrifice after that and so on
and guys exactly just to ask you a quick
question ask the panel a quick question
because we didn't talk about this game
not a lot of what's happening at least
up to this point but how is the end game
in fearuja versus right now is it that
easy for saris to hold
that position
you guys can uh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
a lot has changed uh a rook and pawn
ending where it looked
like everything was even but somehow
black gave up his c6 and d6 bomb like
what if i just push right now c5 yes
like c5
so
they say rooks belong behind past pawns
and he go he went for it
c5 c5 is on the board yes well that's my
analysis oh he did it
there was a there was a
slow um your rook on g8 is too strong
i think i have to play rook g1 and king
f7 first
just to kind of
yeah perhaps well yeah group g1 looks
very clever
and not to drag your pawn forward but
yeah to
to the rook from the g file right so
that it will go
uh
first impressions are the white is for
choice absolutely so let's go king to do
we have to stay on d to protect c1 or do
we want to go forward let's go forward
let's go king b4 right king b4 just get
on with business yeah so go to f7 king
the f7
let's go uh rook two
rook to g1 is on the board so he's
definitely sensing the danger
and where is this rook going
uh we we we can decide it later but
let's just say for the moment we give it
as much
money porn goes flexible
people and girls yeah g poncho
c7 and rook c1 and black
black's
winning i want to say well no
i queen right
ah well the bonzo g3 yeah yeah yeah good
morning yeah thank you very much but we
do go i have a check yeah yeah that's
what i wrote yeah yeah exactly so that's
what i ate was probably not
good
so
uh at the moment i
will keep an eye on this one
on our
on our studio we're kind of thinking
it's still
not completely clear absolute g1 no i
think we have to go back to obama drove
please let us do it absolutely
it's interesting though yes how the only
game that we initially picked up uh
carson and nepal finishing it real
quickly the other games are going and
everything and exciting
dry rook end game all of a sudden it
becomes
becomes exciting okay we do have b3 on
the board and queen d again from shaq's
point of view he has a dream
rook and rook i suspect that a move like
rook takes e5 is actually i'm just going
to
it's over it's because i just don't see
how i'm going to stop these black pawns
it's like the horde
uh is coming down the board and it's
going to be bad
now having said that
like you said white's play is so easy
there's nothing to discuss you just put
everything against the camera
and hope let's invent some lines so ba2
for the moment i'm probably just taking
on a2 right so let's i mean yeah let's
pretend you go a3 yeah so you want yes
protect it past pull on b2 i do so rook
to g3
yes now we do threaten a little
h6 so you go with your
exchange sacrifice right right yeah pawn
takes and then and you go b2 yes and i
was planning to be brilliant and go
knight f6 for whatever reason here
so you do have a nice checkmate on the
g8 square
yeah
okay um all of a sudden optimistic even
though you promote on b1 with the chat
king goes to h2 i'm still optimistic
about white's chances maybe for no
particular reason maybe you'll find a
defense
i'm afraid
i'll have to do something i i if i move
my bishop rook h6 wins queen takes f
takes f6 that's what i was thinking but
then yeah pardon me yeah it's not that
you
have such a such a huge material
advantage and all of a sudden like where
did it all go right
yeah wow
we do have a3 on the board
which
is an indication that players
are following our precepts once again
we're expecting rook g3 i played
i can
i i can sacrifice uh your pieces as well
as anybody
so i can sacrifice exchange maybe i have
to do something a little bit more
like gh7 but wait a minute there's no
rook takes doesn't work now because
queen
correct yeah that's what you would like
to do you want to take on h6 to so that
black cup just with the opponent then
it's check and mate and it's funny
yeah fun and interactive very nice
uh we do
[Music]
that's a menacing
amount of pieces around black's king no
but seriously you can easily go wrong
with black so let's take only five well
that's eliminated bishop we did and then
we
even let you make a queen can he go c3
c3 rook takes c3 right
what oh that's a distraction so that's
b2 you're trying to stop all my fun
yeah apparently this works yeah but that
was that was that was close that was a
nasty queen g5
just for the you know nice looking move
but it doesn't work again well then one
might be uh he's going for it guys rook
takes c5 is on the board
okay that's
like i said
i can sacrifice jordan's pieces and so
can jordan
he's perfectly capable of sacrificing
yeah but now it is important that he
goes c3 and not
i don't know if btw works yeah but
according to what we thought i guess you
just have to open the c file right
uh open the c file then put the pawn on
b2 and it's just unstoppable after that
uh look
it's so very rare that we get to discuss
a position with three queens uh let's
have some fun again it's uh at somebody
else's expense
c3
yeah you can make one queen yeah
i might try to get the fourth one yeah
yeah well actually
that's what i was about to say because
because
my desired knight f6 is probably going
to be met by queen
bishop e6 bishop e6 queen e6 yeah so we
protest bishop e6 no oh the queen on on
c1 defense h6 so what i wanted to say
like you know
you bring everything right and it's
still not enough yeah you brought
literally all the pieces yeah it's still
not enough oh my it's by the way
george d3 is on the board price
three three what a move
gosh that's visual
there was a laboratory
game
that made an incredible impression on me
when i was a kid it was like there was
black pawns on d2 e2f2
one of the games from the match yes yes
yeah of course i remember i went with
this and what year it was yeah 1852 or
something like that
yeah but uh
you don't see
a three
c3
very often right it's not legal wow uh
c3 on the board jumping christian oh
it's beautiful uh
he's he's completely busted
wow the arrow is lost he can basically
resign he can make a few moves he can
try to go queen f4 queen takes f7 then
realize that the queen on c1 actually
protects everything and everything
um
it's a rough position and you don't have
a lot of options right because you're at
the end of the road these pawns are
going and one of them is going to
promote knight takes c3 also b2 also
bishop to b4 but once again this is a
staple of my defense the bishop on f8 i
really like
this whole construction queen to c6
followed by bishop to f8 everything was
nicely understood by van forest and
after that he just started pushing uh
his pawns now this goes to show how
important timing is in chess right
because if he would have started pushing
his pawns and leave the king uncovered
unfortunately probably he would have
ended up on the other side of uh this
result with a win for white checkmate in
the position but he firstly secured his
king's position and then pushed his
pawns really nice game knight to f6
sorry to interrupt you but what a visual
knight to fc knight f6 was quite the
move he takes h6 as mate
he said please take my queen that was
probably the last attempt right right
that was a nice move anyway yeah c takes
d2 and then rook h6 rook takes h6 and
what what remains is what remains now
queen to e6
so
everything yes uh not interested in
seeing a checkmate
gave up his queen take my queen i'll
take yours queen takes d7 said shaq
queen e6
and what you were talking about the
stable
nature of that's resignation right there
it's this bishop on f8 yeah
stable bishop on f8 and yeah
what a game i mean excuse me but that
that deserves a real applause absolutely
that was great the final position three
parts yeah but i mean he worked hard
yeah
the bonds got pushed
uh and i think the other game is over as
well
yeah we have a victor
as well mvl has one sorry in another
super visual uh fashion as well there's
a checkmate coming in next move so a
double checkmate in fact double check
that's a nice one yeah yeah vote
checkmate yeah double check
mate have you ever done that i've made
many many double checks but i can't
recall having played double checkmate
now i don't think i i've done it
it's a very common pattern that you use
double check to check mate on the
following turn right exactly
exactly you you move your bishop
with the discovery by the rook
rook to d8 and this last uh
move would be a check with the knight
inviting queen takes g3 but of course
this bishop is also
checking
so it's a double checkmate uh
how about you christian have you ever
played a double checkmate i'm sure i did
i'm sure i did but not in uh i don't
think in a classical game blitz for sure
i've had plenty of them uh classical i
cannot remember any double checkmate
it's a visual nonetheless me either so
we have two games remaining at this
point wesley so yeah lenders yeah
they're still going and actually we
still have that end game
uh rather imbalanced i must say
the material is quite limited on that
one i would probably stick with ferrule
versus
just because saric only has 50 seconds
and peru 11 minutes
there's a huge difference in in their
time management right there
okay and by the way we did see that move
rook g1 followed by king b4 king f7 rook
h8 we didn't know where to move in the
white room
he decided to go
to
uh
uh-huh he wanted to bring his king over
to the
queen side yeah makes some sense though
right i mean that's not the thing
right he ends up being on after rook h7
check he ends up being on d8 don't go to
d6 yes yes i will do my best d8 is force
because
uh the desirable will get by
would be nice
if not for this uh
nice little checkmating pattern so you
can force me back
but somehow i'm in the way of the pond
maybe
yeah
didn't help no no it's not like king
goes forward like king b6 now
threatening c7 so you're forced to check
king c5 and then you will not check me
one more time but you you'll take the
pawn here yeah
confess that's what that means that's
what you want to do i i i i need the
confession booth i want to bring back
the confession booth i always liked
that g7 yeah check and rg7 perhaps what
i have to do and it's still white well
i'm just thinking that can you be sick
yes
that i could
you know use the shelter but on the
other hand great i'm sheltered but am i
so happy
standing in in front of the pawn
maybe i have to go to c8 right
so i could shelter myself like this
right
here seven but that's the moment where i
could go
when you get to a seven but that's a
tricky point that's a tricky one d6
wow okay uh more tricks
than we expected in this ending how
difficult is it for the players to
navigate christian
well at least according to the engines
this is still within uh
the uh equality margins nevertheless
again i'm only looking at the time right
now 50 seconds is not going to be easy
and this is what hiroshi is trying to do
as well he's trying to find ways uh to
confuse his opponent right because he
doesn't want to give him easy moves like
good to be three uh king to a6 that's an
easy move so rook to h7 king to d8
but how do you continue is the question
to d7 to defend the d3 pawn and maybe
then try to get the king to b6 maybe
that's one way
okay rook d7 check king c8
and then king to b6 and then g4 the
problem is that's the thing it's it
seems like black's moves are quite easy
as well at least forced in the position
right
like you say time being a factor
you you you want to give your opponent a
little rope to hang themselves with
uh not not to make them walk the plank
in a very forceful way
when you actually give checks right yeah
you kind of push him
he will not blonder
d6 exactly exactly exactly that's
interesting well i remember yes like
first half of when you're a kid learning
chess and you're coach telling you try
to avoid the positions with only birds
yeah when you have to make only moves
and later much later on you realize that
that's the easy part right when you
don't have a choice and you're finding
those though
strangely enough it's easier than when
you're on seconds and you
kind of have a choice but you don't know
where to go exactly exactly sometimes
you just got to
you know you try to put
problems in front of your opponent but
then suddenly you run out you reach a
moment when you realize i really can't
force the problems for my opponent i
have to let him discover them absolutely
let him make uh
problems for himself at the times
seven minutes against 58 seconds okay
eight seconds uh how about yeah we were
trying to confuse like does d4
confuse this wow
because i still like my idea of going to
d6 i don't know if d4 okay so let's take
that i believe are no good against
computer if computer says it's a draw it
must be a draw but at least right you
know as a try so the idea so the point
is of course you have to try to go king
b6
and then once i check you but one
question maybe i don't have to check you
maybe now i can go
d3 d3
is that that might be a that might be a
that might be an oopsy daisy c7 is yes
i was afraid of rook takes yeah so seven
you can tell that's that's worse yeah
unfortunately so some probably i want to
say i'm not losing still because of like
checks
it's not what you bargained for when you
played
that will
really upset the
the balance in the position
okay so we have two gamescale instead
i'm just giving you an update i don't
think much is happening in the other one
uh that's the
same
color
[Music]
whoa
but this bond is actually the
the h pawn
but can we keep it that's the question
because he what he's trying to do if i
understand it correctly like king h5
he threatens bishop c3 right followed by
king h5 and just
actually stops it for now
clever okay so now now let's just go
king h5
king h5 bishop 27 and then go a4 and
then you push the a pawn yes a little
destruction and it doesn't matter what
you stop it with yeah
yeah that's a nice decoy i i must and by
the way
do we have that on the board that's on
the board yeah
um it's pretty straightforward you know
a3 you take on c3 and king h1
unfortunately we weren't
playing too much attention to that game
but it
feels like it's one of those where
wesley nicely
escaped
somehow there was some really really
deep and clever preparation in that game
and it wasn't enough uh wesley handled
his business right okay guys well i mean
look at two versus one yeah there's
something to work with
draw yeah draw with only the kings on
the board yeah maybe yeah yeah i got an
extra bishop which doesn't count
but here in this remaining game we have
two versus one
well
yeah but i suspect it's going to be one
versus none soon i think you're gonna
see rook g5 and rook to e3
to mr philidor exactly rook to e3 king
to b6 rook check
king to c5
back to
champion king to d6 and rook
then czech they're telling me that i
don't have anywhere to hide um but then
i go key five
right now
obviously still going it's it's not that
yeah it's not uh
stop stop stop bang bang
in fact yes sir
maybe
it's too late
to look for a draw because g3 happens to
be a blunder maybe
wow yeah yeah
maybe i had to start with rook e3 or
something of that yeah well perhaps yeah
but it's
it's clear that i mean
i must say i might have fallen for the
same trap myself and played g3 rather
without thinking you know i'm cheating a
little bit seeing the evaluation not
even the lines but evaluation five other
moves so basically was g3 loses and all
the
you could go to reasons and so on so g3
itself is the problem for whatever
reason wow and that is not easy to
understand and not at all no not when
you're playing rapid chess and you got
50 seconds on your clock yeah you see
the pony push the pawn right that's how
it works i mean yeah
i mean that's how we were taught you
know yeah but you have a passer grab it
and uh oh
has evon
come to determine that uh
he has blown it it's like it's still
again it's not that it's still a game
it's still a game right yeah yeah it's
just that computer now
heavily favors white and right and in
such positions we can uh
can trust compute a hundred percent i
believe that's well are we in the table
i mean we have we are in table-based
territory territory
yeah like king c4 is a is a strange
decision to be honest
the best move the best move the best
move yeah would you play king c4 yes i
think so in that case just because i saw
that uh you can at the very least you
can repeat you're right exactly i don't
and i have this move
which i'm banking on as white
that i i i wanted to stop king c7 and
all my mostly i still cannot believe
that black cannot trade the g pawn which
is like far advanced possible for for at
least something exactly i feel like yeah
i'm in a carsten mueller master class
that in these positions you should do x
y and z and you make a draw and you're
you're a genius right
and here you're spinning your wheels and
saying
i don't see the draw i mean
you're you're facing a very serious task
e5 e6 rook check e7 absolutely yeah
perhaps and rook to g7 was indeed the
only move in the position that g7 was
the only
okay
oh
wow
with
five seconds on the clock i was about to
say he sure
he sure played it with alacrity when he
did get round to it right
now it's time to pick up some pawns
right
um take on g3 and
is it necessary the technical technical
victory i think
take on g3 is a technical victory
take on g3 then get the king on the e
file in front of the pawn and that
should be a win right
uh rook takes g3
king d5
oh
c7
g6 i don't like g6 i like it
why not that's a an extra pawn
yeah perhaps yeah but king d5
think it's kind of winning automatically
right this
you get short side wrong side
well yeah
you get your king inf
and rook check
how about it it will
try to be the king to e5 can you get the
key anyway
oh but this makes it much easier because
you're going to be rookie
and then you get to keep both pawns
and ferruja knows it right now yeah he's
he's he got this one yeah i think he
does and and he still has almost five
minutes right yeah
that was the downfall for surrey she
left himself with just too little time
on the clock in this end game
and if i was able to find this imbalance
two versus one very nice play by the way
by ferruja yeah but at the same time i
mean again i have to i feel a little bit
sad for yvonne because the move g3
i mean
what an unlikely culprit i mean it just
looks like such a natural move and
everything else would have drawn and
that was a losing move honestly i still
keep wondering how he ended up in this 3
versus 3 end game because before that if
you remember it looked fairly
symmetrical exactly
like no risk whatsoever yeah it wasn't
that philosophy was better exactly
so we are now expecting rook e6 and
something like king of six to king e7
and you just
you're you're you're two pawns to the
good
but uh yeah he's thinking olivereza
so do you go rook to e6 i do
or do you go king f5 and king e6 and
just play that allow the king to take on
c6 and play that position he does
e6 all right so what if i go rook to f1
yeah you you can force white apparently
to to switch to this position with one
pawn but but the winning one with the
king on e6 or even e7 and escorting the
pawn through so first you get the pawn
to e5 and then you get the king all the
way to east right that's the plan god
here we go
king of six
king six rock h6
and king of f5 f5 rook h5 king g6 and
we're going to see a lot of challenges
right
yeah so the game is kind of still going
but by that point i think
again
a big shout out to our viewers thank you
so much for joining us here in st louis
as we're looking
at the gran chester and zagreb
for those of you who would like to ask
miro or christian or myself any question
you're welcome to do it through the
social media of tweets and uh
all kinds of good stuff
i mean we are available nero you can't
believe uh
how of how good our availability is
right i mean
we get a lot of questions uh
including i will speak for the audience
what were your favorite books what books
did you learn the most from
and
it's remarkable
how different our panel
was in those answers
e5
rook uh
e4 again he was trying to make it as
difficult as possible fighting for his
life yeah right right absolutely
and uh
well actually the rook itself is a
little bit awkward on e6 no question
about it i i'm expecting king f6 with
the idea
of rook to d6
just so that you can cut the rook
cut the king off
right uh i would probably play king but
g5 myself rook to e8 followed by e6 just
maybe yeah yeah
by that point it feels like everything's
winning but here rook the d6 so rook d86
is kind of my choice with the idea that
i could go rook to d1
to d6 or rook to d2 and e6
and uh
yeah farouza what do you think of this
young man's uh technique
we saw
some of his best and worst chess in the
candidates i felt
well
candidates somehow it struck me like he
he was not prepared in the opening it
feels like right even though he was a
lot of lot of talking about him be
becoming the next challenger and so on
and so on so i don't know what happened
but he was not up to the task in the
opening
and
really suffered a couple of like painful
defeats exactly what's intriguing about
today's announcement again to those of
you who are just joining us we did have
this shocking news
on this international chess day
that magnus carlson will not defend his
uh title against nepo
concerning that news
magnus had said he would have looked
forward to a new challenger and
specifically mentioned the new
generation of ferugia that he might have
accepted yeah in light of today's
announcement it
feels like maybe that wasn't a
possibility i'm starting to warm up to
this announcement and to his decision
because he left the door open of a
potential return he said that in the
future
maybe i will return to uh the world
championship cycle so
i think what he's doing is uh you know
leaving the crown for a couple of years
letting some other people battle for it
and then come back and win it again in
glorious fashion in glorious fashion
that's the story that he wants to create
right wait a second wait a second
there's a few holes in this beautiful
story this story yeah i just realized
because
i yeah i was trying to stay with the
board you know to sum up all the
conclusions that are made like the lyran
fighting for the match all of a sudden
right and so on and so on and i thought
yeah magnus he will play the new
champion he'll return the cross wait a
second he will have to play in the
candidate correct because he would
guarantee
and he's not guaranteed a spot yet
unless he qualifies by rating yeah
probably he is guaranteed right okay but
he would not be
a second place in the world championship
match i mean he doesn't qualify from the
world championship for example
yeah he's not a runner-up
yes
daddy if we're still going to have
candidates maybe he's uh looking for an
angle to change the format altogether
king to e7 that's uh hesitant
but i think he suddenly realized that
king e6 king takes c6 rook c2 check
might get another file yeah push the
king away king e6 with the idea of rook
c2
uh
whether you take the pawn or not it
suddenly becomes very attractive a king
e7 must be winning
but king e6 might
as well also be a winning move
uh
way in guys how many illegal moves there
six right i can tell you i can tell you
five of them are winning and the sixth
one is rook f2
he's losing
but i like this move i think that this
move
with the threat of rook c2 keeping both
pawns
whoa yvonne allows him to keep both
pawns so you can play rook c2 now yes
and then instead of having an awkward
rook i actually
have a great rook
now the only reason why i would have
seen actually magnus continue defending
his title is just because he's such a
numbers guy and he loves breaking
records he said that he's going to go
for this 20
rating he is always looking for the next
challenge now
the problem with the next challenge is
most likely going to be that seven
titles won by gary kasparov right he
wants to get to that number the way he
sees that is that even if he
relinquishes the title right now he
still has the chance to come back and
get to uh
to that number right so i think this is
the way he's looking at this whole drama
so
uh help me with gary seven i'm counting
gary six and a half
six because the first match was aborted
yeah six and a half i guess yeah yeah
yeah i think that's actually how he
called it as well
six and a half right
uh
well uh
i was going to say that
the world championship match that magnus
won
in dubai
was the first time you really had what i
would call a clean victory
uh against sergey karyak and
fabi
he went to overtime so it wasn't like he
convincingly won in the classic or
something like that against vichy he had
some troubles i think actually in the
second match but all right but only
early on like yeah
in the late stages we kind of already
knew that he's the clear favorite to win
it exactly
at last the king has a lot arrived on e8
the pawn is about to arrive on e7 yeah
but the funny part you will have to
have to abandon the sea pawn at the very
last moment
true
and you'll still have to build the
bridge or whatever use the umbrella
whatever you call it yeah
yeah exactly
and how do you do that first you could
you give a check on d7 try to get the
king on ca that yeah are you trying to
be a perfect right right
uh playing it yeah well actually what do
you do you go to what to d
to now right d2 yes you give a check yes
get the king to c8 when i go c7 then i
get rid of this
and i come back to the stuff i know
like that no but that's true
yeah
right
and by the way it seems like ali reza
did spend most of his time uh trying to
figure this end game out from 17 minutes
at the beginning of the end game against
one minute now he's at 40 seconds
against 30 seconds wow
but he will
find it
finally he figured it out yeah rook uh h
8 to f 8 and then your king
manages to find the square of seven
that's that's the fourth way out
and there's no tricks
time honestly yeah
sometimes it's
really surprising no
wait a second
can he play rook to d7 oh you have to
play king city
jack king ca and c
c6 is king d8
that's that's the easiest of the easiest
and he went to this idea
but why
to force the king to take the pawn that
was a very strange decision for me too i
i'm not quite sure
okay now rook czech and king f7 yeah
czech and king f7 just wins right
and now we can zigzag our way right back
towards the rooks now it's resignation
title and series of checks
good call there christian
as we have
another win uh we out of our five games
mero three decisive results
out of five three decisive results out
of five and also what i would call it
the game of the tournament already that
uh jan
van forest versus uh mama the year of
game was just ridiculous
k3 b3 c3 are you kidding me right a3 v3
i don't think i ever had that i mean
i've had my my fair share of passers
don't get me
but uh here we have it uh nero after the
standings after round one alireza
perugia maxine vashiela draft jordan not
forest tied for the first
as always in these blitz and rapid the
two points for rapids
and one point the traditional scoring
system for blitz because we're playing a
single round rob in the rapids and a
double round robin of blitz
we're going to take our first oops but
first let's jump to zagreb with
alejandro with a guest
thank you and we are here with one of
the victors of today's round maxine
bashar lagarov welcome to zagreb great
way to kick off the tournament yeah
friends says i think doing well very
well two out of two for the french team
here in zagreb take us a little bit
through what happened in your game it
seemed like you just took the initiative
from the get-go
not really like i'm not happy with what
i did in the opening like
it's knight a6 97 it's not here of
course it's when the knight is on d2
uh and here of course i'm worse like
i want queen d to f5 but of course
numbers but gtx e6
made me think like i was
getting away with it and
yeah i just took the pawn and i'm
assuming i'm doing very well here
which is basically what happened so
um
like yeah f5 was a good move to
again take initiative threat on f4 and
yeah then it was more or less over
yeah it seemed that he fell apart
quickly after that of course we are a
little bit limited in time we have five
minutes into the next round but we have
to ask you we have to ask everybody the
big news came out today what are your
feelings as a player that is
participating in the world championship
cycle yeah by then i was not surprised
anymore like at first i thought he would
play but
in the last few days it was clear magnus
wouldn't play why made you think that
well what made it so clear um
well
basically
what was
being told you know in the
is a
sideshow yeah like uh
so internal um
internal sources internal sources so
anyway
i mean it's magnus decision
for me it doesn't change
anything for now now the question is of
course um
it will not of course provoke a change
of cycle
this time
but maybe for the next cycle actually so
then
things the best thing the best thing is
of course to get everyone at the table
uh
magnus other players to to think about
what we want uh i mean it could be that
we don't change anything but
um you know it's a pity of course when
um as we're number one and world
champion for ten years
it's not part of the cycle anymore so
but
um
so we'll see in the next few years do
you feel that this being the crown jewel
of the chess world do you feel the match
is worth a little bit less now that the
number one player is not going to
participate
uh nice
i mean to be
fully honest i thought it was already
worthless in the sense that
i think it's not adapted to to our time
so i thought there
are probably better ways of uh
designing the world champion
uh of course it's been tradition and a
lot of people don't agree with me on
that
that i know but
i still think that so
it was maybe time for a change and maybe
this move my magnus will um
will be a catholicist
well we certainly hope so i agree i love
rapid and blitz so i definitely agree
with you i would love oh i
didn't necessarily mean to switch to to
rapid and it's like there are other ways
other ways well we'll see if fiji
changes it up i know that you have a
game in a few minutes so we'll let you
go guys maximum sherlock graph starting
off excellently here
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the rapid and blitz from
croatia 2022 miro we are ready for round
two pairings and what strikes your fancy
uh well magnus carlsen hear this name
yeah well he lost some cars and magic
because he is still a world champion we
know he will not be after the match
that's a little bit sad but still i
would like to stick with his game
against apollo other pairs by the way
games have started already which yellow
graph against wesley saw one forest
against dominguez savage against mahmoud
yarov and nepomniacchi is also a very
interesting one considering
yeah yeah marquee matchups across the
board here but you're right you know
once you've once you said magnus carlsen
and we are after all chess
lovers
uh you kind of got to go with
whatever it is that magnus carlsen is
going to bring to the table now having
said that i clicked on magnus carlsen
game and it gives me wesley
hmm
yeah could it be that it's
like a little bit hidden at least uh
well
there we are
there
here we go
it's vessel and opal off versus magnus
and
looks like magnus played a karo khan
two knights variation the karo khan with
knight f3 i've always felt that this is
actually allowing captures and knight f6
and because you've already committed
yourself to the knight f3 you don't have
that 92 stuff but anyway having said
that bishop g4 is
after all probably
one of the other most principle moves
takes takes and i think
so many people have
played e6 as well as d takes e4 i would
be shocked if we weren't in the
thousands of games
from
our database queen takes f3 but again
vessel and
topolof true to his style
of the two bishops
one very important trap in this exact
position and of course i pride myself on
falling for everything at least once i
have played d4
uh with the understanding that i was
going to follow it up with c5 and knight
c6 and
get the center my opponent played bishop
c4
that wasn't what i wanted i ended up
playing e6 in 92 and i was worse uh
magnus knight f6
knight of six yeah i was about to
mention
for whatever reason they do sometimes
play night knight f6 e6 and uh d e
are
again more standard for me
this
kind of invites e5 is it is it
completely ridiculous yeah perhaps
uh
to play
i honestly don't know what what's the
plan yet but you know what i mean he's
very standard right
i mean just follow this line a little
bit before c5 i mean we have to
sacrifice on g6 but precisely the queen
d4 no e6
yes and then black on demise the center
goes c5 bishop d3 doesn't understand
anything right falls for queen h5 check
please wonderful wonderful we like to
hear so it's a very yeah very principled
for me
you only take with the queen right the
bishop takes g6 band right i mean and
i'll as ali alejandro would say with
understanding queen takes 66
with
uh a lovely lovely checkmating pattern
none of this happened why
because d4 d4 an invitation to take upon
yeah no
if you accepted
bishop to d3 yeah i think it's bishop to
d3 i think it was michael tall who first
proposed this pawn sacrifice i remember
from his 1960 book on the world
championship match and he just seemed to
be like and you play
yeah
yeah you play upon that it was like it's
okay quite interesting is that uh
topalov definitely is aware of what he's
doing he's just blitzing out his moves
right now he certainly is
he analyzed this before magnus seems to
be within his theoretical knowledge as
well but not as sharp and it definitely
seems like potentially the bolov might
have gotten a plus now i see c3 coming
on the board i see the two bishops i see
g4 g5 uh as a potential for white i
really like what white is doing right
now
especially if you can get in the move c2
c3 then i just think it's a two bishop
advantage straight up and the other
thing about
having the light squared bishop
is when i play the move c3
is your play really really is the
minority attack
and the bishop on d3 makes it really
really hard
to put that whole
plan into motion yeah so what i'm
thinking yes could it be that the plan
for black is actually to go for e5
and that's actually except the the
isolated pawn yeah so let's say
yeah
c3
with or without casting yeah like
because
because bishop g5 was well right exactly
and this is what you're suggesting is
that basically if this happens i think
black does reasonably well
i think
in the absence of that the the choice of
the minority attack i think you're
rather required by the way magnus
may be feeling a little bit uneasy
played the move night before night
before in order that was my first
reaction yeah i should trust my
intuition i thought then it's a check
and you will have to go knight d7 it
looks awkward but yeah yes since magnus
played it i feel much more comfortable
with suggesting move like night before
yeah like before yes so what do you
think yeah
really really an excellent move uh
let's analyze it shall we okay i give
you a check which is on the board on the
board
recognizing uh boldly
the obvious uh threat to my uh
my uh king and rook i think that means
a4 b5 is on the board wow they are
blitzing okay that's very serious right
i'll drop back with the bishop as has
vessel and
played well and apollo is blessing he
has 25 minutes while magnus is only 21
minutes
okay
and again from white's point of view if
i can go
a4
and c3
um
[Music]
yeah go back
you'll make me go back yeah the other
hand at least the minority
yeah
the one that you were talking about it's
so difficult to get
in uh
in the position
knight c6 voluntarily
intriguing choices
okay so now again if his idea is to
try to chase down the bishop the move c2
c3 is very similar
and now
again
bishop e7 castles castles and then do we
play for b4
or
g6 yes
exactly i think we have bishop d6 on the
board yes yes d6 is played
uh perhaps it's celebrity um are we
are we
in book or out oh definitely out of book
definitely out of book at least
according to my database there hasn't
been any games up to this point now uh
he kind of burned some bridges magnus
that is with this idea of playing the
move b5 i was looking through some of
the big games and actually there's a
game between erdos and a grand master
from uh hungary quite solid grand master
and firuja from recently in 2021 now
this one played out like this you're to
see a g4 and as we were mentioning g4 g5
and it seems like uh white is getting to
black's castle yes but there's no castle
and that's exactly what ferruja took
advantage of and he played this move
king to d7 now
check what's happening in the position
right now b5 was already played on the
board i cannot imagine a king coming to
d7 anymore in this particular
configuration so what i'm seeing from
black is a potential
short castle nevertheless that's going
to be prone to the attack of white on
the king side let's see how this one
develops bishop d6 uh any takers for the
immediate g4
uh why not
here without
i mean i'm not kicking away the knight
but the idea is i just want to stake a
little territory
and if i ever i get
this with a pawn on g5 there's issues
it's not so easy
for a counter strike in the center by
the way
rook c8 and
you you were mentioning christian the kg
i'm not going to castle short i'm going
to go king d7 in king c7 maybe steel
not to d7 but just to keep the options i
don't believe it
no that's my analysis board sorry i put
g4 on yeah
yeah no he cancelled he cancelled
instead
but still it was met with rook g8 magnus
is not rushing to castle i see castles
uh rook g8
okay now after castle uh for white
definitely g4 is not as potent anymore
no
if you do castle i can see a knight
landing on h5 like knight g3 knight to
h5 then followed by queen to g4
there are still a lot of pieces swarming
around your king bishop drops back to c2
that's going to put some pressure on the
b1 h7 diagonal it's still not safe to
castle even if you don't have to worry
about this g4 g5 so quite an interesting
dance that's been going on right now and
it does seem like at least up to this
point uh in topolov is much more
familiar with the way this position
should be played let's see is if as the
game develops magnus is going to be able
to get his usual edge
one thing uh before we just take a look
at some of the other games uh if i'm in
vessel and shoes i really despise this
knight on e2 it's not working it's got
to
find a better job
and whether like you said it's knight g3
knight uh h5 or actually the place i
always kind of felt at home was the d3
square where do you know this from here
it's not like i'm questioning but where
it comes from it's very interesting
games of glitching
a tiny book lectures of the grand
petrols and probably never translated
into english and he was stating he was
stating that yeah the knight on d6 in
carlsbad because yeah talking reverse
reverse carlsbad structure yeah that's
so interesting like little patterns here
you notice once and then
they're just sort of reassuring that it
is a good square it really is it really
is uh let me try to bring in some wow
i'm not oh i'm on the wrong i understand
why i can't bring in any games
because i'm in round six
around around nine i mean
uh we're in the future
uh that forest where where is the shack
game
oh pardon me i was looking for the net
it's the next one downstairs yep
downstairs
and there we have it against uh
perugia
and that that is actually surrey versus
mom in the arab so on the screen we have
saric versus mohammed yarov
and then on my analysis board we have
the napo versus farrugia again
it really looked like um in the
candidates
nepa was playing alone you know i mean
he was just kind of there was a serious
uh distance and for
whatever reasons for ruja
you know
what as you said you know had his
opening issues
uh did nepo two out firouza in the
candidates i i know he won with black
i'm just trying to remember i think he
won the second half as well that was the
he won the second half with black pieces
but what happened in the first half
between them
because he also beat him in romania in
the grand chester in romania so
definitely nepo is beating furuja
wherever he catches him
at least up to this point so first
definitely some psychological maybe
problems against nepal let's see if he
can overcome them right and his position
suggests that in this one at least he
has quite a decent uh chance of doing so
well it's funny uh farouza is one of the
rare people who are willing to play
king's indian defense in modern day
somehow
even though the pawn is not on g6
it has that
you know once a king's indian player
always a king's indian player queen d2
um
your take uh miro once again
i'm not sure if it's that
that's brilliant for black right so
knight d4 is of course he's asking to be
to be played but i can see some
i don't know maybe once again i'm
carrying it away with all this rook g3
stuff
you know the king and uh
you you weren't convinced that white was
lost in the game yeah yeah
still take as a personal offense
the king was not checkmated but you were
attacking with two rooks bishop and i
hit a queen
so you're trying to say this is this one
is not enough
but then i don't know what white's
supposed to be doing yeah he played this
natural myth night before um we were
i remember in um
warsaw it was also in the candidates
there was the c5 move against the
structure it was with richard richie
rapport and duda
white was getting in the c5
in this case
if white had just simply played the
simple move knight f3 then black would
have secured his knight with c5 and said
uh what are you doing
uh
jan's decision
f2 f4
is for me
a very very difficult decision to make
because
in many ways i feel like i'm burning
bridges with this move
um
yeah once again
well you can do you can play this move
with kind of two
there's two possible scenarios you play
this movie it's very very good it gets
to five i don't know you play f6 you win
right or you feel like if you continue
in a slower fashion you're getting
outplayed okay and that's why you try to
mess things up and i'm afraid it's the
second
yeah because i will play knight g7 g6
which by the way is just played
and you're you you have a double attack
i really i'm really forced today
yeah and that was the whole problem is
that suddenly dark squares around
your king are
yeah and i'm probably have to
i'll probably have to follow it up with
a cop yeah and then it's an interesting
thing about these structures right so on
paper like if you only look at the pawn
formation you would say white's pawn
formation is better right yeah wonderful
still
until you yeah you actually see where
the pieces are right and then it's a
knight on d4 it's this double g pawn
protects the king very well fantastic
and all of a sudden it's it's clear that
black is better i don't know how much
better but like he's better right and
and i think a big problem is also that
rook on g3 right there's going
of this knight on d4 you actually have a
rook lift like rook a7 d7 rook a7 f7
sometimes knight f3 is a direct threat
yeah so that's not very pleasant for
white a piece i say so at some point you
want to exchange the knights right you
you want to try to go knight to e2 the
problem is knight to e2 runs into knight
to f3 in all sorts of scenarios right
you have to be super careful in this
position and i don't think maple really
enjoys what he's doing right now i think
he missed knight g6
yeah and if you're forced to make a move
like king h1 inviting something like i
don't care rook f4 queen of queen h4
black is seizing
the initiative you were just mentioning
that
farouza is actually having a very
difficult
score
against
nepo of late
do do you know what their head-to-head
match-ups are christian between nepo and
alireza yeah i can only remember uh the
latest ones right they haven't been good
for alireza romania candidates um i'm
trying to remember uh what their
matchups were in rapid chess and i
cannot really pinpoint the exact time i
know they played in paris last year in
the grand chester but i don't think they
met as many times in uh rapid games
nevertheless classical chess definitely
nepo uh especially in the last few
encounters
cool just trying to decipher
uh ferrous t-shirt that's a nets uh
that's a basketball that's a brookie
shirt brooklyn brooklyn nets yeah yeah
brooklyn in the house uh maurice would
be pleased we have the nets in the house
there we go
i think it's an okay maybe i
i said something wrong but i'm pretty
sure that's a nets game
ah that's an nba short t-shirt
all the teams all the teams like this
that's what the producers are saying but
i don't believe our producers i know
they're very very very dodgy producers
uh these days
[Laughter]
yeah yeah
so
neville paused this can you see the
alternative i mean
sometimes
f5 not necessarily the move i'm so eager
to play but what i i like what you were
saying any trade of the pawns on e5 the
black king side structure
your king is so beautifully cocooned
it's like you'll never have a discover
check you'll never have an opportunity
to throw anything against my
my king i once had that against misha
tal i had it but with the colors
reversed g2 g3 h3
in my candidates turn them into
montpellier my king on h2 was just like
oh dream you know
on cloud nine unperturbed so f5 uh
and look at the face by the way there
was this kind of little scowl
there that
nepo made like
well his poker face was never his best
suit
either nakamura uh but
is it that difficult uh for nepo
christian
it's definitely not easy i mean uh
the engine is saying that already black
has a pretty significant advantage wow
um more than a pawn so yeah
more than a pawn advantage and this is
remarkable and maybe we can take a look
at what's happening in the world
champions
yeah vessel we'll just go back and just
check on it for a moment because this
was the minority oh a queen trade i
think that is something that we're just
saying
shaking his head magnus would be
what
oh but that was very very bad play by
by vessel and to
to
to to to force uh
a queen trade and allow b4
well
basically a weakness on c3 that is going
on that's very difficult
the the
magnus is
magnus has cleared the worse
the worst is behind him and i think he's
just better at this
when we left it here
knight f4 to d3
was met the requirements of the position
absolutely of the commentators as well
you know
a queen trade is a dream come true this
is an ending that magnus
is certainly not worse and
very very likely to be better he's
willing to play it yeah right i mean
knight to d3 knight to d3 he ends up
playing i'd rather do it with the queens
on the board there's queens on the
border with black pawn still on b5
preferably yes exactly uh
it's kind of easy to see what
black's moves are all about he's going
to play knight a5
plays it immediately
and i was
going to say also the knight can
land very
comfy
on the c4 square rook fc one and uh
comes to c7
signaling from the bishop
also disturbed but
very
straightforward and uh
no i mean
just did everything wrong how do you
defend the c3 pawn do you put the peach
pawn e1 or do you bring the king to d2
i don't think i'm in time to be you're
not in time to bring this yeah so bishop
d2 and then
yeah
to end up on e1 yeah you know in seattle
we would say seizing the defensive
with both arms you know
i've got it yeah uh but now the biggest
thing about black's position is that i
can also swing between the b and the c
files correct i can go rook c8 i can go
rook b8 b7 and put some pressure on the
b file you have a lot of weaknesses yeah
and the a pawns are on the board it's
also a thing to understand about the
minority attack i believe yeah so
sometimes uh white would be
on time to play a3 before you go b4
right and then black is supposed to go
a5 and they're basically pretty much the
same structure but a pawns disappear
exactly and then you have one weakness
you're not very happy with the bishop on
e1 yet but at least uh it's the only
thing that you have to defense
uh let's jump across the pond to zagreb
and say hello to anastasia and alejandro
what do you have for us guys
yes
he keeps asking he would give a knife
here yeah
thank you yasser and welcome here to
zachary tell us a little bit about the
playing hall it is packed and
everybody's ready to see these games
yeah actually the plain hole is really
really nice and fabulous i would say
it's red and
there are many many spectators
in the plane hall today it's fully
packed with people and it's really great
to see them all of them um people who
love chess they came to watch their the
games of their favorite players right
and
also we can see that all the players are
really you know concentrated on the
games they come
straight to the plane venue and actually
everything is happening in the same
hotel we have to explain this to our
spectators that we are in the westin
hotel and the plane area is here and the
players have this great opportunity to
go back to the rooms and rest if they
want so i mean i think everything is
great so far and it's actually a big
deal a lot of the players like to go to
the room prepare a little bit with their
seconds and it's showing in the game
specifically this one between jordan von
forest and linear dominguez because it's
so difficult okay you can win a game of
chess but to surprise lanier dominguez
in the opening that is almost unheard of
and jordan he looks relaxed he looks
like he knows what he's doing and he has
a very nice position he just played this
amazing move bishop e3 and i absolutely
love it it looks very counterintuitive
you're doubling up your pawns if you
take on e3 take on e3 but it's the
tactics of the position what do you do
with this knight on b4 it's difficult to
move it anywhere on d5 for example you
get this kind of weird structure but
more importantly your pawns are hanging
d5 is attackable with rook d1 and you
can even take on a7 directly
difficulties for linear dominguez and
jordan starting with a bang in round one
might even take round two exactly bishop
s3 looks really impressive it's not the
move i would think of you know when i
play the game yes so so far so great
absolutely well back to you guys in the
studio
thank you both for that that move uh
by jordan van fors bishop e3 is a very
visual move because again
it's uh you don't intuit that you're
very happy
to uh accept the double pawns but just
as they were explaining this night on
you know on before is like in
the air and it's a trapeze artist with
no safety net i mean if you have to play
a move like bishop to d5 and we do get
these trades these pongs are certainly
not
as weak as this one and this one in fact
uh white looks like he's just going to
go upon up and for jordan the dream
start i mean of course jordan is a
wonderful wonderful player a little bit
in the shadow of a niche gary in terms
of dutch chess as a niche gary is still
number one but uh jordan is uh
saying hey guys uh don't forget about me
uh we'll certainly keep an eye on this i
also wanted to go to the game of mvl
versus wesley so
wesley starting the tournament with two
blacks always an awkward
beginning if
i can put it like that but wesley is
doing a fair job
i think white's for choice because
the pawn going to cease
upon me upon going to be sex could
always
yeah well it is potentially disturbing a
little right
right yeah
but uh okay we'll keep an eye on this
one as well i'm gonna jump back to let
me tell you we have a couple of
unbalanced positions already right so
like right
as we said well it's clearly better now
against nepal
but also carlson is much better against
the polyps so we discuss both games
there's the endgame in one and now we
have the live board from nepo and firuja
i see and uh
it looks like uh
an infestation on the dark squares you
know like we see
you know uh a coach i can play these
moves myself you know bring the rook
double your rooks on the open file
and uh
looks like napo's
so the only thing there's a lot of
things wrong you need to worry about as
black right now is how to avoid the
exchange or at least how not to allow
knight to eat with a temple on the roof
right so you have to drop back rook fade
probably knight to e2 and i think if we
exchange the knights in this variation
and not allow black to go c5 and take on
d4 with the pawn creating a pass pawn
and defend it past pawn if you exchange
the knights like this white is going to
be just fine right that's why i think
that
maybe rook to f7 first or rook to f6
first and then uh mid knight to e2 with
the move c5 and this is the sequence
that i think at least i'm anticipating
that we're going to see because white
has to do something about the knight on
d4 or create his own strong outpost in
the center on d5 now the way to do that
is to attack the knight on d4 with
knight to e2 wait for the move c5 and
then go back knight to c3 and go to d5
and then we're going to see the battle
between these two knights which knight
is going to be more potent and i have to
say the knight on d4 makes a much better
impression to my eyes and just in this
variation with 92 christian knight takes
e2 queen takes c2 queen c5
queen e3 is going to lead to a better
position but probably
with the double pawns that's the thing
is the question is it enough yes i i i
for the structure on the king side i'd
like to have queens and rooks and
knights and bishops and more pieces for
a checkmate and i i agree with you
wholeheartedly that uh
knight e2 is definitely yeah he did yeah
but at the same time yes i do not see
black playing luke f7 i mean if only the
previous move was in rook f4 it implies
that you you are going the head yeah
queen g5 i can imagine queen h4 whatever
yeah but like
he will impress me great deal if he's
gonna you know just admit the perhaps
rook four was a bit lousy i go back
queen g5 makes a lot of sense to my eyes
he has played queen g5
forwards always forwards
so the question is 92 which uh perhaps
yeah that's what i'm trying to figure
out
like a check is nice but what's the
follow-up to this check especially with
pieces hanging
rook on f4
why does queen g5 stop now i understood
the idea of trying to stop knight e2
with queen h4 because
the e4 pawn is hanging
but why did
why does queen g5 stop knight
e2 do you have some knight f3 idea
that's a check but maybe not more than
that
so knight to f3 king h1
and then
i don't have any follow-up if i go queen
to h4 that's probably not going to be
enough
yeah okay so let's go back let's go back
knight to e2
again it's one of those it's beautiful
what
it's beautiful 92 rook f3
you have
and queen g5 you check oh my goodness
knight takes c2 and then
then you take i mean that's the hard
part that that's right
that you take on d3 and that's
that and automatically you get these two
rooks versus the queen
and this is exactly where you like your
king to have extra pawn shelter exactly
yeah like rook a2 d8 and then you almost
guarantee that yeah the advantage of two
ropes that you can attack any weakness
two times yeah exactly so two pieces
versus one piece it's no longer like how
strong the queen is exactly uh
that's nice that's really nice
quite a sophisticated variation all
right
knight e2
rook f3
easy to fall for all for a rapid chess
game that's a great trap i mean i got uh
i mean that's almost like you know an
all points bulletin you know like
breaking news everybody uh look at this
rook a3 what a trap
and let me toss it over to you christian
is uh linear in trouble absolutely
lanier is in trouble as alejandro and
anastasia pointed out uh it does seem
like van forge just simply surprised his
opponent in the opening and
unfortunately for dominguez he was
unable to bounce back from that surprise
and this is what we have right now
bishop to e3 bishop to e7 was his
decision and after rook takes a7 well
that's just simply a pawn and show me
your compensation i do understand the
king on c1 is a little bit exposed but i
do have this shield the knight on c3
nicely protected by the pawn on beto a
great uh outpost for the position and if
you don't have anything going on at this
point as black any immediate attack
against my kingdom this is just a pawn
and it's a very important pawn also
because once i exchange the rooks i'm
going to be able to involve my king and
slowly push my b-pawn that b-pawn is
going to be worth a piece at this
position unfortunately it does uh start
to look quite hopeless for black so van
forest could potentially start with a
banging two out of two that's just an
incredible result for the young uh man
from the netherlands but mahmedi yarov
also seems to be having some problems
against saric in this position i was
looking a little bit earlier right now
the waters seems uh to have calmed down
a little bit the bishop for the night
got exchanged in this fashion bishop
takes d4 and instead of knight 64 i
think rook takes c6 leaving especially
now with the involvement of h4 and h5 on
the board giving me the nice outpost on
g5 for night i think it would have been
better for white to keep the knight and
the bishop on the board instead of that
this is the position that we have right
now 10 minutes for star rich 15 minutes
for mamedyarov it does seem like this
one is probably going to uh be a tame a
draw but let's get back to the match
that we were having our eyes on the game
of the round potentially the one between
yanni pognashi and ali reza what do we
have do we have knight to e2 no
we do not have a knight coming tonight
after queen g5 we saw the move king h2
yes uh miro just kind of sidestepping
uh that lovely little trap with rook f3
uh rook f8 rook d2 and although white
has avoided all the traps and stuff
uh
visually uh black's pieces are really
way too sexy pressing
h5 is he threatening knight f3 again
knight f3 champion might be a threat
exactly because he takes you have enough
takers on the owner
so knight f3
jesus threatening
and it's an awkward threat to stop
because yeah it's like what they do so
queen to g3
would uh avoid that
but it kind of invites chief there is no
92 you're not exchanging any of the
ropes yeah yeah yeah
no here i just kind of like uh
i think it was michael schubert who said
it very nicely uh one side is doing
the other side is watching
black is doing yeah he's doubled his
rooks on the open file he's played g4 g5
and he's pressing
uh
white down so how do you
how do you deal with 92 in this position
instead of queen to g3
uh
i think uh the idea knight f3 i take and
then i have maybe knight g3
well first of all i i win a part you do
you do so you can take on e3 and then we
exchange the rooks and the question is
how is that endgame
i would jump at it if i was white just
because i don't like the old you don't
get checkmated right yeah i i don't like
the alternative so
uh but then
but i don't have an alternative yeah i
have to take right yeah rook takes e3
knight takes
[Music]
yeah no real choice here now you're a
pawn up but also you have double pawns
right so it's not as of a significant of
a pawn that you have and i do have some
weaknesses to attack so maybe i can
start with king g2 um stop you from
entering on f2 and then go replace this
this would be a tricky right rook f4
then yeah rook d6
and we have some sort of uh maybe a race
it might break down to the question if
this g7 and double h pawn win against
the h pawn because i can easily see like
a lot of trades now yeah well that's uh
that's a three to one
majority i would be
i'd be heartbroken if i couldn't win it
with the with the white side um
nice
nice variations guys
but it's very important that
90 to be met by knight f3 because as
we've discussed any trades of the night
is quite a liberating feeling for
white's rooks
and that boat looks very concerned and
he's got ooh
we are about to find out yeah yeah and
we have a result
that was an uneventful draw it was it
was that was the queen ending and again
you know wesley is quietly
quietly doing his thing
which is he started the position started
today with two blacks and by the way
they're storming
right into that variation that we've
been looking at
yeah off we go yeah like this black is
better and furuga turns into a rooken
game master oh exactly exactly
i i somehow i i feel that karst and mule
miller will be like eagerly pouncing on
a rook and panna in-game master class
and we do well pardon me our analysis
has brought us to this position we've
been expecting
king g2 that's the question
or king g3 i think it does it makes
anybody makes more sense right
but it does no it doesn't matter because
we're going to have an h4 check and
there will be an x so then maybe it's
king g1 that has to be played
wow
okay
then then we call the arbiter and say
please uh wand my opponent
one more time
king g-1 uh that would be quite
so the problem is why king g1 and not
king g2 is that whenever we go into this
line with rook f4 rook takes e4 there's
this check on e2 which picks up the a to
pawn as well precisely how do you avoid
that i guess the only score is g1 i
think nepo sees it and if the king is on
qi1 that'd be remarkable
and as we keep an eye on this we also
magnus carlson
he was enjoying i want to say an
advantage against vessel and i just
didn't know
how much it was well at some point uh
the engine was you know just
shouting at magnus being like plus 1.8
which is almost quite a considerable
uh but wait a minute uh am i missing
something the knight was on d7
yeah it went to f16
very nicely and then
retweeted back
uh so i'm a little bit confused here
yeah uh
i would have thought that his intention
was to play knight e4 yeah exactly
it doesn't look that this is the way you
make progress by shuffling the knights
to d7 back to f6 and so on yeah
something about the world's champions
play here doesn't make
a compelling impression
um but it's it is still white who has a
very difficult task exactly
kind of a little bit of a fisher random
position here for white
all the pieces on the first rank and
not on their original squares though and
maybe this is also part of his strategy
to try to wait uh get the clocks down to
the last three four minutes and then
change the character of the position to
be to be sure that veselan's
clear weakness in the last few years has
been his
running down on the time
getting
behind on the clock and then
messing things up in the resulting time
trouble uh
for magnus he won't he wouldn't be the
only person
reading this script
saying i got i know uh vessel and you
you you've been uh blundering positions
in time trouble
okay well we'll keep an eye on this game
again we're going to go back to the ali
farouja he played king g1 because
he did play games
yeah and these two players did start
with wins in the first
uh game today so
no nepo nepo drew against batteries
against magnus it almost felt like a
victory because it was so easy
easy draw with black against magnus you
could count it as a victory
oh yes king g1 uh was that the key move
then christian i mean he's still much
worse right now the question is how much
worse are you losing or not how do you
continue right now rook to f6 are you
going to try to stop this invasion via
d6 or are you going to go straight for
the pawn with the move rook to f4 it
does seem like rook to f4 is
relinquishing some uh part of the
advantage after rook to d6 who takes e4
this is already not as bad for a white
it does seem like that's the case so
came to g1 definitely a testing move for
uh young ali reza who once again will
have to show his prowess in rook and
games and he showed that to us against
sauric let's see if he manages to er
well the problem as i saw it if he
didn't play rook f6 if he did go with
the rook d6 idea
and just rook to d7 and you know go
after the wikis on e5 and a5 okay but
now we're just trading parts what if i
go rook to c5 like how do you continue
you take on a2 i take on e5 and then
what exactly and then i'm hoping that my
three
to one majority
uh we'll bring the bacon i'm not sure it
it does we do have rookie too and i do
expect your move christian rook to see
five to be played shortly miro what's
your guess uh well i well i'm just not
sure about one thing
so
if we say like rook f4 was forced and so
on that there was one thing to look at
honestly like
a air move for black h4 i would suggest
okay and then is rook d6 rook f6
possible at all yeah sure because if
if this is possible if this is the same
game ah you have rupees i was going to
go in almost every case but then it's
you know like rook f3
and you have awkward time protecting the
h3 guy kenji till there is a check
forcing you to h2 i mean
i'm passive i'm passionate in these
cases might have been more favorable
version of the same that's what i'm
trying to say i'm not saying that black
is winning but right
he went to a little bit straightforward
way
understood you know it's funny uh
i was actually resisting the move h4 and
why was i resisting the move h4 because
i always kind of thought that was a
pathway for my king
you know
on a good day you know my king ends up
on h4 and i get
something going and by the way we do
have rook c5 rook takes a2 quickly
played times one of the clock times
uh do you have third
eight minutes for nepo 11 minutes and 30
seconds for ali reza right now in the
previous game event against ivan saric
he entered the rook ending with a
considerable advantage on time
did farrugia here he's getting
less of an advantage against time but we
know nepo is a player who's going to be
playing
very very very quickly because the
position is not favorable
and it's just his nature to play fast
again your take uh of course we're
talking advantage black but
is it in your view i mean you're so
excited i don't think it's enough it's
nice it doesn't feel it right yeah so i
don't know the result what results going
to be in this game yeah
no they say objective evaluation should
be a draw
object okay so here so so let me play
the devil's advocate for just a moment
so imagine that i'm playing
these very strange moves h4 g5 all right
so let's try a4 let's try to exchange
the pawns actually that's what i want to
do rook to b5 rook to b5 let's say i
play the silly move g5 let's go b4 right
exactly so we kind of get
and and here's a kind of a demonstration
of
where i'm
at with but i go rook to c rook to b6
right yes
th
go to h5 and now we just stay like yes
and then we just get no i go five six
six you can just go rook c6 king h1 king
g1 shuffle is the king
and i've got a problem uh everybody
wants to play
to the h5 square
uh so i
okay it just in this moment if i had
brought my rook immediately
uh behind
yeah i guess you could still
just assault give a change
i bring my king to f5 but that's got to
be a draw rook takes h6
okay well uh
saving this game would actually be
i would say quite the success for uh
nepo
and magnus is still drilling that
position that end game but nothing
actually has changed much
by the way big developments in the
jordan van forest game the more i'm
looking at this the more i'm liking
jordan's game a lot
i mean he's basically his king is
sprinting
uh over to the king site for safety and
in the meantime well he's a couple of
pawns
points
but that was great calculation by uh
jordan actually yeah before this
allowing rook takes b to it does look
threatening because the rook is with the
support of the bishop on the b1 h7
diagonal it has some interesting checks
route to c2 and it does feel like the
king is getting in danger but everything
was very well calculated by jordan i
have to give him props for this one nice
uh
and after bishop g6 says now he's like
uh get on your your your running shoes
your sneakers and get out of dodge
well actually
it was a funny way of going wrong like
to protecting against c2 with rook d2
we love our mating patterns here in st
louis we enjoy
showing
these back rank mates uh
with the nicely supported bishop yeah
but after king d1 yeah he's getting it
it is yeah
it is getting tough
white didn't win the game just yet but
it feels very very good chance too yeah
it feels uh very promising yeah just
imagine we run to f2 right we somehow
moved the knight to f4 ideally and then
i'm done super safe yeah also i could
take this pawn yeah right back to f3
yeah that that's the other way also very
safe
and uh extra pawns
in the pocket guys but uh the magnus
other story of the tournament right now
it seems to be mamadiarov he's really
struggling because he might be losing
once again seriously against ivan sarich
yeah losing his jordan van forest and
then losing against ivan saurage the two
lowest rated players in the event that's
not a good start for mohammed er this
was the major piece
ending with queens and rooks which we
thought was like the wars was behind
yeah right exactly but now you're just
losing a pawn don't you well not
your king might also somehow
yeah rook h5 was actually
an incredibly serious threat your king
might just end up walking into a mate
but this is the pawn you're talking
about and
well where's the compensation
there's no compensation
i'm sorry i i have the compensation
because i also have the pawn and the
pocket and you know what it's not only
an extra pawn i'm afraid it's a very
depressing scenario for a defender
because the king is weak till the end of
the game exactly right so white it's not
the case where you want to to go to a
rook end game you attack the king
enjoying the extra pawn i think that
yeah that's almost impossible to save
okay but
he did played a very good move rook is
second round
maybe he's getting the rook end game
after all yeah with queen f4 check right
i don't think he wants to see that white
that is because that b pawn is going to
fall right okay so what are you are you
reckoning on queen g5 do you like queen
g3 or queen g5 queen g5
obviously feels a bit more threatening
the problem is i'm cutting the action of
the rook so now
i i don't like that i want to keep their
queen on g3 a bit when these are kind of
like g3
in any case i thought i was playing
queen of four kind of the same yeah okay
but this is a completely different
scenario because now i can take on f4
and go rook to eat uh king to g3
followed by rook to e2 so i'm not losing
any of the pawns
yeah but that's
but you
kind of i mean
i understand you have a three versus one
majority but in this case my king is a
bit passive i understand yeah yeah i
mean i might just play a5 so let's go f4
let's see yeah christian is right in
fact yes i think i can just push my
estimate yeah you just lift everything
king g4 g5 kg5 well i don't know how
you get your king to g5 that's okay
let's go even h5 now
key f6 and let's put the rook on the c
file just to get out of dodge
and this is the key moment do i have
any improvements it's like you yeah you
can get your pawn to g3 but i don't know
yeah still not easy
so what we're looking at is a as a
variation for
shaq after queen g3 queen f4 we're
getting into a rook ending where he's
clearly suffering and he's doing his
best to hold
uh but it's suffering and maybe when you
play king h7 i have to stop you with h5
uh-huh way back when right right when
you're nice yeah that's gonna have to go
h5 that's actually clever
so that the king maybe black then had to
go
but then i get my king to g5 first
exactly exactly if i do that then you're
just
and just start i start to really worry
about your majority you you have a
positional
advantage with the king i just wanted to
go to the game between these former
world champions uh vessel and uh topple
off as white against uh
magnus and well bishops of opposite
color
you have to give uh
uh vessel and some respect as he's uh
he's pointing very f very
feels very close to
a kind of equality give me king d2 and
rook back to b1 and
i don't see why it should be worse i
have one weakness
the pawn on c3 but i'll have it
adequately protected with my king on d2
and my rook on v3
it's not so easy
for
magnus to attack it
g6 on the board by magnus yeah g6
some beta the surprise
seven king g7 rook h8 h5 is what but
it's a kind of a reverse thinking so he
played g6 he must have done it for
something right
it's not the plan that would cross my
mind exactly because one of the things
about the move g6 is it kind of
encourages me to play knight e5 because
it makes it much harder with the pawn on
can you two
too that's a hard move for me to guess i
was
i was
absolutely certain king d2 yeah but
maybe you were running maybe you were
running on the knight c4 check so maybe
that's
why that's why king e2
hmm
it might be that this one is just you
know
just the move can you do yeah hard to
say
okay uh
so
and let's just jump to the ollie
whoa no that one
not much does this look familiar yes
yeah i think yes
[Laughter]
this is so long ago but i i really do
remember like a venus fly trap
playing a move like rook h
rook h5
and watching my opponent play g5 that
was a little bit awkward wait a second
rook never
left the building you know it was just
like
stranded let's go back to magnus game
because i think he's actually breaking
through right now is he he's finally
breaking through yes king jesus has
changed okay king to g7 might not have
been the best move i think he had knight
a5 bishop a3 and just pick up the pawn
but what's going on with magnus yeah
knight a5 bishop a3 it's not
and then take on c3 right
yeah
rugby one wait a second bishop a3 rook
c2 maybe he was well then there's a pin
on the b file that's very unpleasant
good grief that's a terrible yeah
so he's playing it slow but maybe this
is giving topalov some extra chances to
defend
uh
no unexpected miss i have to say because
he did play the move knight to c4 so it
does make sense like he's aiming towards
that square
not that i'm a big fan of the move but
maybe knight e5
rook to b1 to b1 whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa
doesn't that invite bishop to a3 no it
sure does
it's both bishop and then night one is
that they have a little traffic jam
though right if you go bishop a3 and i
go rook seats
roxy
b8 oh yeah
so bishop a3 makes a lot of sense even
the rook to b8 now you're in time to go
rook
yeah
b3
bishop a3 rook to c2 right
maybe i do not kill roxy too guys
by the way magnus is clock time three
minutes and 45 seconds against four
minutes for topolo
so magnus is going down
this time is actually keeping
a head on the club yes knight to d6
well this looks
nasty
uh just to mention 94 going after
my weakness
also
something to worry
if i don't have enough to worry about
there's also a possibility that my rook
to b8 could
do some damage is there
can i get away with knight e4 95 or is
that asking too much
but how do we
how do we go about the c3 pawn then 95
94
i was uh knights rook to b3
[Music]
uh
with trembling hands
yeah but that's exactly the feeling
even though i'm on the edge a little bit
right like magnus is slow playing it for
sure right he could have been kind of
more aggressive but but still the
feeling is like white is he is yeah he's
about to play magnus is in control still
uh bishop a6 ridiculous 94 rook b3
it's not easy for you to double up
against my rook on d6 then yeah so why a
d6 heals he's going to lift the rook and
then you get it that way b6 and so on
yeah it's a lot of shuffling around but
as long as white is unable to get rid of
the weakness exactly magnus is in
control exactly
and last but not least what's the killer
for
f3
f2 f3
the idea if you go rook c8 i'll go king
d2 you go bishop g5 check i'll block
so
f3
at least controlling the e4 square
this is the fear that the knight coming
to e4 is
he played knight e5 by the way too
disruptive
i was i was really worried about this
knight dropping in so let's see let's
see that's it i see something to get
like series very worrisome for vaseline
can i go c4 after knight d4 or is that
too much
knight e4 it's probably asking for too
much
with this guy yeah that's that's a pawn
maybe i can try to go knight c6 and then
take on c4 that was kind of my
hope my hope yeah it is kind of a hope
because rook d5 feels very threatening
right now exactly
rook d5 if you take with the rook you
can actually take it with the bishop
strangely
really yeah
what a what i mean it's a swindle it's a
swindle obviously but but yeah but if
you can if if bishop c4 works then all
of a sudden white's okay exactly
oh my um okay so we do have the position
with knight e5
and we're thinking knight e4 in the move
c4 and he has played c4 he's on the
board he did play knight force he falls
on the board well the problem from
white's perspective he had no choice
once that knight landed on e4 you
weren't
saving the c3 pawn anymore so he had to
push it
now he's
kind of
in a sense
well nothing but
you know these he it's hanging on
tactically by a very very thin
thread
but if it halts it holds yeah that's
you know i've never beat this kind of
player myself so when i would not
believe it hold and simply would not go
for this position exactly it amazes me
what people do in you yeah like the
calculators the fobbies and the vicis
they they find that narrow window and
they they're they're they're very sure
of their calculations too
nepo i sometimes i feel he's coffee
housing it but then he comes and he
explains everything perfectly i've seen
everything
[Laughter]
and you're mystified yeah nepo indeed on
on a
want to say on a good bad day or yeah
you know when he's getting a bad
position but then bails himself out and
then he would explain that yeah
everything was under control speaking of
bad positions of bailing himself out how
was he doing in this game
yes he will not let it go i think he
will he will hold it this is almost like
the identical pro
position we were looking at instead of
putting the black king on h5 put the
black king on f5
and jordan
jordan van forest
uh an
early surprise leader as he starts with
two out of two or four points if you
will as he beats
lanier we'll take a look at that game
and another big surprise i have to say
is mamedyarov just completely getting
crushed in that end game and this is
exactly what we have we've seen this
idea coming from from a very uh a long
time away yeah this idea of just pushing
the pawns here as well as now with the
king on h6 stuck i could potentially go
rook to a7 and have ideas of g4 g5 and
czech made the king right right and the
eh file so things are getting extremely
dire also f5 is a threat this is just
pretty much lost for mamedyarov well
that's uh not a great start for a shack
going into this event but let's not
forget we looked at his rating his
rating is at 26.99 going into this event
on almost 2800 in classical chess under
2700 in rapid chats definitely it
doesn't seem like rapid is his time
format and he's showing it right now in
the tournament and there you have it
this is the list that we currently have
at the grand chess tour and you see
chakriarma medyarov 32nd in the world
26.99 frankly that's shocking that's
shocking yeah i mean you know shaq is
such a
an outstanding player we're used to
seeing him in the top five top 10 of
classical ratings and there before we
just kind of carry it forward to wrap it
but i have to say
blitz is blitz and a lot of people are
just very good at blitz and classic and
rapid is that awkward in between it's
it's not an easy
time control
to truly master magnus right now under
one minute guys
and knight 36 is on the board things are
getting complicated for him
wow
i think he's just now realizing that
rook to d5 bishop takes c4 is just that
below that tactical sequence that allows
white to get back in the game that's
remarkable
and he's going for rook d5 very very
very quickly
did he just blunder
why is this a boner no i mean bishop c4
allowing bishop c4 ah it's that maybe
there was no choice but
uh it is yeah
because if you do not take what about
knight takes e7 and bishop c6 97 yes so
somehow i got over excited yeah but by
the way yeah why don't you just
knight takes e seven representation
bishop c6 is that an exchange
uh not really i take and i go oh take on
d4
rook to e3 okay very quickly right into
that variation that you mentioned
and we're not going to see the trade of
the rooks that's
yeah that's obvious but
that's a second game like this yeah i
was about to say yeah it just feels like
a an echo
of the uh game
from round one with nepo
but this is definitely not magnus wanted
out of this game
no he was looking for this is minimal
right now
like okay you could say cashing in the
chips early but having said that to be
seven wait a second still rook take can
i take on defense what's the plan after
rook d4 is
i would say
so you're going to have to defend that
four versus three exactly exactly and
you're right that's what's going on yeah
and we're about to see bishop takes g6
is because yeah qe3 with the temple
falls into this bishop c5 which is
rather
which is rather nasty
and uh this bishop coming to c5 and this
rook coming to a4 is a
if a position i would want nothing to
deal
to do with myself but bishop takes g6
king takes g6 that's the play four
versus three that christian
was mentioning
again
you know
has squeezed a lot of players
um right and it's all about the pawn
structure right how do we assess that
pawn structure because it is very
atypical
king takes g6 rook takes system c7
how do we play this one do we put the
pawn on f4 or do we he's taken taken the
players
after rook a4 the players will catch up
with this
uh and you're a5 a5 okay excuse me
so he does put a pawn on f4 for
without too much hesitation
and i guess he hides the king to h3 now
is that the plan
yeah and the rook behind yeah why not
yeah just king
king to h3 always
nice and safe
behind behind and whenever you try to
run with the king perhaps the king will
cut you off already yeah but how do you
do that i i'm still not convinced okay
so let's put i think i have to go
all the way to a2 right or a3 or all the
way to a2 i want to get it all the way
to a2 a2 yes
and then f6 e5 and you are hinting at
the second passport by the way and i'm
trying to get my king i can also bring
my king to f3 f5 in that scenario
yeah that's right
yes yeah but your king will be on g1 by
then right okay
it doesn't matter i go f5 king g5 rook
right yeah the king can be anywhere yeah
but you're right
he's going for the whole variation with
a3 with the idea
it's an unusual pawn structure
with or without h5
you may want to play for f6 and e5 wait
a second but at the same time your rook
will be tied down the king will be kind
of bound to g2
uh h2 right right mate so
may i strangely enough he's like go all
the way around with the king with the
black king when the pawn is on a2
yes you go to go to b8
get the king somewhere where it's more
active and only then proceed with this e
f6 e5 why not it might be a kind of a
very very long plan which eventually
works uh by the way the other route can
get pawn up nepo against
he's already like a dead draw
and shaq escaped
he escaped oh really
rook and games are always a draw somehow
he escaped that's crazy because we were
thinking
that
ivan sarge had done all the hard work
he'd put his pawn he was going to get
his king to g5 in the nicest possible
way
he had a pawn on
wow
uh just in this moment we were kind of
thinking that it was all over
king g5
yeah
and king takes
he played h5 i think to g5 the problem
was rook takes b3
okay this is what he was concerned about
no what happened saric is not very
pleased with no
but look king g5
rook takes b3 rook check
uh not even taking with check by the way
but just simply rook check
your king would have to i presume go
back and g4 this is just yeah you're
hopeless
yeah yeah
we just saw three pawns and they were we
we have to go let's jump to the magnets
yeah sorry because i i do feel like that
pawn on a2 is
so i guess your only chance is to try to
you have to go to h2 right king h2 g5
one on a second i think i like this move
actually you see you take it i take with
check you want to take it with the rook
and then when you play for e5 i'll have
a pass pawn with g4
by the way just a breaking draw
it between nepo and farouja uh again a
big
whoa h5
well that must occur
five seconds
that's
h4 h4
yeah
and
i'm so what if i give you the pawn back
right he has to go g4 no
and i think white has to get you have to
stop the king that that's uncertain well
then he's afraid of rook f1 though
look
for when i take on a2n king h3
and then i give you a check at the end
on a5 when you take on g ah you get the
two versus one h and f
devon i never had that in my career
which supposedly is a draw i know it's
first of all
it's supposedly a draw but i never
wanted to be tested
that is for sure okay uh guys
this was
this is not amazing anymore they were
making some very very difficult
decisions
very quickly were they correct clear
there's a lot of mistakes in i was about
to say yeah it feels like um but just
look at the clock i mean it's no longer
yeah it's seconds literally seconds to
apollo's down to nine eight
you know
and we could go back to that variation
with rook f1 is e5 above
e5 is definitely a move but i have e6 at
the end i take with the pawn and when
you take on g5 i go e6
you're on right right
we're going straight for that variation
guys this is the one i i was worried
about was having to defend and f and h
bones f and h and by the way can you
take with the rook here ah that's a
given
check
and then take with the rook and you keep
the e yes
yes
remarkable
magnus is
once again uh squeak squeezing his
opponents and
successfully
check check
he might be winning this one guys
i think so
paulo
is a big opportunity a couple of times
i'm guessing
especially close to uh the position that
we currently have on the board when rook
to f1 came on the board f5 was the point
yeah
yeah i already figured this one out was
critical could force f and h yes
yeah yes it wasn't obvious yeah
in here
with the e in h pawn
yeah
magnus is gonna take it guys
wow score his first victory in his usual
style just his grindy style
i must
playing the bishop takes e4
and getting that bishops of opposite
color ending i think he
he had been so fortunate and had saved
the game at that point
not true yeah simply not true
who saved was shock all of a sudden
that looked like it passed the saving
point
went far beyond right
and
still some technique uh required here
i mean i think you can just go king f4
give up the h-pawn and uh
trundle with the king escort i think
this is what he's going to go for yeah
once the king lands on e3 that's just
right that's over
exactly
well are you sure though i mean it's
still
i think it's a little longer
yeah yeah i understand and anyway that
that's seemingly the only way you can
make progress right that's why you go
for it so i go e4 now you give me you
have to give me a check and then lose
another campaign don't you give don't
you go kf3 first that's something
another question
i like that i like that's more precise
for you because kh34 i can go to e2 and
that's kind of your your little insuring
okay but it's still yeah it's winning
yeah probably it's good enough but uh h3
now of course king of three king of
three if you like
he likes
important victory for magnus oh huge
racist
for his confidence
because he usually does
not miss this type of opportunities out
of the opening he got a completely
crushing strategical advantage the type
of advantage he loves to nurse
and that's it and he almost blew it done
deal
it's over e3 resigns and for
you you're talking about confidence of
magnus carlsen how about the confidence
of vessel and temple off he's just kind
of been
shaken here as
he thought he had done
good enough work to save the game
started with two whites against mvl and
magnus and lost with uh
lost two games with the white pieces
that's not a great start for vaseline he
will need to bounce back to get that
confidence back
uh talk to us a little bit i didn't see
enough of the jordan van forest game
let's take a look at what happened in
that one uh well i mean we left it off
somewhere around i believe it was here
right after this move king to d1 and i
said that the king is actually escaping
so very very nice play by jordan and
very well calculated this is what i mean
by calculated at this point
this position came on the board and f4
was a critical decision because this
allows rook to uh b8 and now you have to
calculate f takes e5 rook to d2 is not
as compelling exactly because of the
patterns that we were discussing rook to
c7 you don't have enough time to take on
f5 because of rook takes c3 take on c3
rook to b1 this is the pattern the
checkmate pattern that we've looked at
during the broadcast as well so f65 was
the precise calculation that he had to
engage in and take take take this is
just a simple conversion right now and
alejandro actually in zagreb is with
jordan van forest the leader of the
tournament alejandro what do you have
thank you we are here with one of the
winners of today's round actually the
very important game here jordan van
forest has won against linear dominguez
jordan i was telling the viewers winning
a game of chess that's hard but
surprisingly near dominguez in the
opening man that's almost impossible and
you did it with this move a3 tell us how
it came about yeah i thought it
might be interesting like for rapid game
it's kind of innocuous but
for rapid game i mean white doesn't risk
a whole lot and if like goes wrong you
might get a small advantage with white
and kind of for rapid game i didn't want
to risk too much but maybe hope for a
small advantage so that's kind of what i
did and he generally goes for this
positions with black like the
symmetrical english so i thought there
might be a possibility i get it here
well and certainly went right into it
tell us where he went wrong it seemed
that engines were throwing out equality
at a certain moment yeah right so um he
played well and then here perhaps knight
takes b4 is just a little bit
complicating its task i don't i wouldn't
say it's a bad move per se but e5 is a
clean way to equalize
and here you have to find a surprising
move f6 or if um or e5 and f6 and it's
not that obvious for you because you
want to get some pieces developed so
that's what it did and i kind of thought
i remembered up to rook a4 but i guess i
was maybe perhaps wrong all of this prep
ah
not too much i mean you can do a lot of
prep in a little time these days so
um i i thought i knew of the rook a4 but
i might be mixing up there's a lot of
different setups and i didn't over
prepare something just i knew this idea
of k4 like and the knight on b4 is kind
of a bit stuck let's say
um and then after short castles i was
going to play 94 and then i suddenly saw
bishop e3 and didn't see like where his
knight would go at all like i was gonna
play here perhaps and then grab the two
bishop i'm actually blundering group d4
okay it's very good i didn't do this
i didn't see rip d4 at all little
details of course for the audience the
bishop is hanging but also this threat
of knight d3 let's just move the bishop
somewhere knight d3 check of course
picks up that rook but a little bit of
luck and a ton of skill because bishop
e3 and it seemed that he couldn't answer
properly right i didn't see what he's
supposed to do well apparently there's
no like good solution anyway so i think
he's just in trouble here and after that
i thought i converted reasonably well
but i'm never too sure of course of
course in a rapid game you can't be so
sure but you ended up actually check
rating him yeah yeah an unusual
experience yeah that doesn't happen too
often but i think by that point it was
anyway losing i guess brilliant start
here in the rapid for you how's it feel
today
yeah just very good because i think i
played it last year and i won two games
in total so i'm already equal like in
that uh in that sense but of course um
you know it doesn't get any easier i
think i'm playing wesley with like the
next round so it's going to be very
tough to continue like this of course
going three out of three though i doubt
it but i just take it as it goes and i'm
already very happy regardless let's say
absolutely well you're the one for us
with a great win four out of four points
remember that rapids count for double
games in 10 minutes let's go back to the
studio thank you thank you thank you
jordan and it's that time where we
introduce one of our favorite items cue
boutique
as always has things on sale and
tell our audience what
they're looking at yeah i would i would
guess it's such a sport yes very good
i'll tell you more it's a
gct chessboard yes
branded
premium 20 inches the new roll-up board
featuring the official granchester logo
i would call it red but it says burgundy
and cream squares
2.25
inches squares
perfect on the go and for the travel
wonderful wonderful all available at q
boutique and as why we take
as we take a break we will share with
you some of the scenes from the opening
ceremony at zagreb see you for their
third and final game of the day
[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to zagreb we
are going to have the opening ceremony
of grand chess tour starting very soon
10 players including world champion
magnus carlson the challenger yanni
pognoshi and other top players in the
world will just take part in the drawing
of lord ceremony very soon
[Music]
and of course i'm very happy that this
tournament now has a lineup from magnus
carlson yandy pomnishi and all the best
players in the world so that's again
that makes this place unique thank you
very much all for coming
i hope everyone will enjoy this
tournament and i wish more
more black to everyone i would like to
thank
for the hospitality here in croatia and
say koala hiratsuka
[Music]
of course i like to be in zagreb as your
opponent ceremony was very nice because
was a pleasure to have the prime
minister with us and
you know some
nice moments we have
two world champions here it's always a
pleasure to
meet and see gary and i'm very i'm a big
fan of gary also i'm very thankful to
the croatian government and for the
prime minister gracing us with his
presence it's always nice when
you see chess getting so much importance
prime minister of the country was here
and it's clearly a country where chess
is has a good tradition
[Music]
it's been an amazing opening ceremony
and all of us are looking forward for
the games so let's get back to the
action
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
hello everyone and welcome back to our
coverage of the rapid and blitz from
zagreb croatia we have to
rapid
games under our books the history books
mural
what's our standings uh sir the hot take
before the tournament you tell me that
there will be one guy leading after two
rounds and he will be from the pool of
the wildcarders
you know i would pick magnus
with all due respect yeah you died
amazing job so far two out of two and
the fashion he will he won both games
very very impressed very impressive and
uh the pairings for this our third and
final round of the day
yes so carlson white with zambriel well
yeah
against the palo verde letting nepo off
the hook but still on plus one facing
the follow-up who's very very
uh yeah in a very bad shape it seems
nippon dominguez
saved by shaq and so against one forest
i'm also very curious to see you said
wesley saw is doing his thing and his
thing was to make two drawers with black
to get
white for the first time in this
tournament and try to press with whites
precisely that's exactly it and
again i will start with a heavyweight
match-up we're going to come to jordan
because i always like respecting the
tournament leader but magnus carlson has
done something
different against mvl mvl of course is
noted for his um
i want to say neidorf but queen takes d4
knight c6 and queen d2 that's the wesley
so jordan van forest game i would love
to see the magnus carlsen mvl
uh game and uh this
i just don't know enough about this take
by magnus this knight c3 knight c3 queen
d2 that's magnus's own invention against
the neighbors right and the theory there
used to be g6 instead of e6 exactly
theory you know like
right yeah and sometimes they even talk
about issues
of funny stuff but he played e6
christian and then one there was
actually a very big game in that g6 line
uh between grishok with the white pieces
and mvl with the black pieces
yeah i don't think it was the candidates
but it was a very very it was it was a
second leg of the candidates in in yeah
that's why i didn't think it it was from
the candidates because there were so
many candidates it was the first leg of
the candidates then the second leg of
the candidates and the last candidates
so many candidates
what is this data theory about the move
e7 e6 so e6 has been played but
definitely not d5 so this is the
surprise that we're seeing from mvl and
he immediately uh bolts out from the
board so that's quite surprising this is
a big hit by mvl that he prepared early
on in the opening against this b3 line
bc uh d5 is a novelty knight to f6 was
before played a6 as well tried to get a
much more of a standard sicilian
position no
let's go for this d5 pawn sacrifice we
have this position and potential by the
way e65 is not the only move knight to
b4 seems to be a move as well but it
takes d5 knight takes d5 bishop to e6
we're going to get
well i have to say probably uh the type
of position that nvl has deeply analyzed
at home and this might become dangerous
for white nevertheless magnus carlsen
maybe he is aware of what he's uh
supposed to do as well let's take a look
at the camera and see whether it feels
like he's surprised or not what do we
think about his facial expression right
now and we actually don't have the
camera he would look surprised
i mean this is a very uh unusual uh
gambit as black i mean you just don't
see this types of thing uh mirror but
let's break it down uh yeah
and there
uh does magnus look surprising i think
he does yeah i think he does
uh although he's pretty good poker face
uh
he just came from the world series of
poker well he just looked there like
okay you did surprise me let's break it
down for our audience he takes e-takes
now the first thing i start noticing is
i'm not really happy about this
construction
i see bishop before i see d4 i see
issues
so i feel like i'm compelled to take the
pawn well he might be going for it and
and i feel like
if i'm going to
take the bond
maybe i want to
you know uh evacuate the diagonal would
you like to play bishop e6 and allow me
to trade queens that's the question
because the alternative could be queen
f6
okay
queen f6 and then yeah and bishop before
another alternative is actually queen to
e7
queen e7
7 check as well yeah just to uh get
everything out with tempo
yeah then knight f6 followed by bishop
f5
uh everything's getting kicked around uh
i'm
well actually i'm not so sure i'm happy
to get this feeling that you know
if you remember you hit me with night
before and i've compelled it by king
deewand i've got issues i'm not i'm not
happy
and uh just checking on the lifetime
between these two uh wow have they taken
a measure of one another and once again
16 wins against magnus is something to
be louded but again i see a kind of
domination but you know it's
it's it's pretty one-sided there
i mean no question he's getting in his
tickles as mvl but uh
how many draws
30 draws
so almost as many
as yeah magnus won as many as yeah 28
wins for magnus and 30 drawers i asked
victor korchnoy had he won in 1974 the
world championship candidates final and
become the challenger and if he had
played against bobby fischer the
must-win 10-game system what would have
been the result and
victor said
bobby would win 10-5. with 32 draws and
we would both be in mental halls
that 32 draws was
10 to 5 and 32 draws that looked like
their score
interesting i i wanted to ask you
christian uh what did the
what what does the engine believe is the
best bailout line for uh well first of
all queen 35 is on the board it is
yes and we haven't seen a response yet
by mvl which kind of surprises me knight
xd5 seems to have been the best move now
the whole idea of the position and the
uh the the problem that we were facing
uh in white's position was that very
often this bishop to b for creating the
pin was coming on the board with a lot
of problems on the dark squares now the
way you can solve that is with this
maneuver also some problems with a queen
to e7 after queen to d5 and putting some
pressure on the e file the way you can
solve both of those problems is by
taking on d5 and then dropping the
knight on e3 that's not very natural at
the same time right knight to f6 and
then not knight to e3 not take on f6 and
by the way we do have a move on the
board it does seem like after queen
takes d5 queen to f6 your recommendation
uh mira was played by mvl let's uh take
a look at the camera and see queen to f6
that i'm not sure if recommendation but
you know
first try uh i like this move because i
wanted to say i think queenie seven
might have been met by queen e4 by the
way do we have some tricks like bishop
b2 bishop a3 is that
uh
yeah so windows are always
is that something that might be on tap
in this position
that that's a move i have to tell you
that's a visual castle queen takes c3
right and i don't know like castle queen
takes c3 bishop takes a3 is still not
right
yeah yeah
queen a1 my king escapes and actually
probably you're just fine with
yeah maybe you
but at first the
bishop a3 might
look good but maybe just bishop b6
bishop e6 all bishop before to start
with him
or bishop to b4 to start with and then
if you go queen to e4 for example now i
can start thinking about bishop to a3
because i have long castle whenever you
get the king to d2
so those are some options that we need
to consider uh yeah i think that's a
an alert just to show the audience
what you spotted rather quickly and it's
still not over bishop to d3 but then you
have to look at queen takes a two ideas
and yeah it's just a wild position
bishop to b2 is on the board by the way
okay so i mean he basically threw down
the gauntlet with queen f6 again your
move queen e7 was uh
nice but here he's
i mean you can't allow castles and
you're just simply much worse your would
be upon down and this bishop on b2 will
soon be a monster
so you have to
by the way the engine recommends bishop
a3
okay so apparently it does work
it does work somehow yes so bishop a3
so how does it let's try to figure out
so castles seem to be the only legit
move in the position it sure looks that
way to me as well
castles
and then you're not
immediately forced to take you could you
you think
it's actually not that
complicated or it doesn't lead to any
like immediate killer uh blows uh queen
takes c3 and then just knight f6
just develop the pieces basically okay
okay makes sense
at knight c3 here we don't drop our
queen back to d2
yeah
force this situation i'm not 100 sure
i don't know if this looks so dangerous
you know right
by by circumstance
by a very strange circumstance they were
supposed to play a match
no castles
no castling between vladimir kramnik and
veswana thondan a brainchild of a
vladimir kramnik was a a chess variant
where you're not allowed to castle this
looks like this looks okay no castle
even though one guy caught me i did
cancel the kingdom too it looks
but this is a bit shocking you came up
with this ridiculous d5 sacrifice
super strong and then you don't follow
it up with immediate blitz play after
she takes d5 it's a little bit shocking
because if you don't play bishop a3 by
the way you're much worse right as black
and you need to follow up the line that
we actually were just looking at yes
quintet queen to a1 king to d2 queen
takes a2
and then the line continues and it does
look from afar that you might be getting
checkmated with black pieces you know
you you played perfectly yesterday queen
to c4 was the right move
nobody ever says that about me anymore
you played perfectly
there was a very strange move also queen
c5 the idea that you have 94 right
now the idea was if i wanted to protect
my bishop
but check
check 94 that's and i'm back
where i started but you do take on d1
yeah i wanted to say like
otherwise i was i was trying to
discourage queen a2
but uh
not very successful how is mvl not aware
of this i mean you have to be looking at
queen takes d5 and bishop b2 right
but
how is the most natural rook to e1 and
now we we go into this wild variation
[Music]
that's why i keep silence i'm trying to
understand what's going on after yeah
you take on e6 and then i guess you
don't have and king d8 and yes i'm
telling you and what's going on no
castles rules going on not only no
castles but like break all the possible
principles as well
yeah and now you go queen to d6 queen d6
and draw and i guess if you go king c8
you have problems after bishop c4 bishop
e6 and then back three bishop d3 or
bishop d3 bishop f5 yeah right yeah
that's one of those great
draws right king e8 queen e6
really right
but wait a second can i really go to c8
but again i'd like to echo exactly what
you were saying christian this whole e65
a novel approach
that was
properly prepared we expect from mvl
and then magnus plays queen takes d5
bishop b2 the most
likely moves you can play
and then max
mbl goes into the think tank and you're
kind of wondering why
bishop a3 is forced
i'm not preparing bishop pizza it's kind
of the weirdest [ __ ] well i think
one of the things we like to challenge
ourselves too is to make a prediction
usually before the first round but it
was the breaking news that stopped and
we have a lady anastasia
uh we're gonna give you
the
the whole floor all right
take it away honestly who do you have
who's your pick
well for me
i think that we're going to see a repeat
winner i'm going to take maxine bashar
lagrave he is the world blitz champion
i think it really depends on if he gets
in this move bishop a3 or not but we'll
see what about you anastasia i think
that i will pick up this time wesley saw
of course magnus is already booked so i
cannot really pick him so i will i would
like to pick wesley so i think he's of
course one of the best players in rabbit
and blitz and i think he is the one who
can compete with magnuson if they start
this race so this is my pick and i gotta
say i was sweating my pick because
bishop a3 seemed like a hard move but
bishop a3 on the board nice and sorry
who booked magnus
was was that you yasser miro is
i guess i'll book him all right i'll
pick back this okay oh secretly
you don't have to ask twice
you can emphasize you can double down on
christian the christians back varusian
by the way also uh went with the number
one seed
by uh rating there but uh miro you
you're the guest yeah you're the guest
of all okay if let's say if i'm trying
to be creative correct leave magnus
alone yeah yes you'd be surprised but
how about
mr who won the candidates with round to
spare in nepal very strong play yeah
let me go with nepal uh
i look i desperately want to say jordan
been forced i desperately want i just
think that he's up against too
many
monsters in this event
ali raja has a lot a lot that he wants
to um
right the ship from
from madrid it's ali reza
for me okay okay
so we've got a pretty good mix uh
of course christian you know he went
with the
number one seed he's not a very creative
man it was a very polite thing to do
right
but it was a smart thing to do
stop the punches guys it was the smart
thing to do and guess what
the exact position that we have on our
our analysis board has appeared
mvl played the move knight c3 eschewing
the early queen a1 check and putting the
ball in magnus's court what are you
going to do
against queen a1check and queen takes a2
and
it's
i think it's time to bail
so queen c4 for the line with a little
check
here and
give really to go for this perpetual
yeah and it's actually very a very nice
perpetual so you you have to go for that
perpetually you try to get away from it
yeah like take quint d6 king to e8 and
say okay you're threatening the move
rook to d8 right exactly maybe i can go
bishop to d3 i'm two moves away from
checkmating you i go knight f3 rook to
e1 i'm checkmating you
but the problem is after bishop to d3 i
have knight e4
which is really nice oh
and that finishes the game so you cannot
do this that's a visual if you cannot do
bishop d3 then you're you're pretty much
forced to go forward
black all of a sudden
try to block with the knight i
understand it's like kind of taking in
which moment uh crazy amounts of risk uh
well not the e7 but d7 yeah
i'm not that naive yeah my d7 might work
like e7 surely doesn't just check
exactly
to make sure we were both reading
uh read i don't know
my instinct is that bishop to d3
knight f3
yeah absolutely it just
developed this kind of trap right yeah
the king doesn't feel great let's just
take a look around the horn and uh now
that i've got skin in the game i want to
look at the game between ali riza and
vessel and topoff
this looks like a petrol petrov it must
have been petrofia with this queen b3
that was a
key feature was that a surprise for you
by the way that nepo played the petrov
so successfully in uh madrid
uh while i'm trying to
suicide win against richard rapport yeah
i remember made some easy comfortable
draws it's just that i'm not sure what
part should be more surprising him
playing the petrov or doing that well
with it yeah because petrol is a solid
opening of course yeah
and well he played it during the world
championship match also game with bobby
was amazing game uh this is the game i
have between shaq and
nepo um
wait a minute wait a second
am i getting a second chance to pick
as in chess you can't take your moves
back it's a sacred thing that all
commentators share you know our love for
uh getting our predictions wrong uh
what's
what happened yeah what happened is shaq
just looks like he's doing that
wait a second but also i mean part of me
logic of the game is one thing and moves
that were played but why so quickly
what sacrifice why is she quickly i
don't think it was sacrificed i mean
yeah like a lot a lot of stuff has
happened
like compare carlson and mvl i
understand
wow
that happened very very rapidly and we
think that uh
jan is on the back foot uh i think he
just missed king g-1
at one moment right here after rook
takes e3 queen c2 i think he just looked
quickly he's talking to three he thought
it's a perpetual and he thought maybe
that's the only explanation i can
come up with but yeah okay but then it's
it's a part of me but it's a childish
mistake absolutely
absolutely sometimes you do have these
blind spots and nepo plays sometimes
very very quickly so so you're not sure
because he calculates so well too you're
not sure what times when he's making
these
mistakes or
uh blind spots linear dominguez by the
way guys
magnus and mvl are bolting uh into that
variation with bishop e6 and the
exchange sacrifice okay let's and there
we do
we we're right with you on that
exchange i think we're going to see a
perpetual guys
yes that might be it again a marvelous
opening novelty there by mbl playing
dividends you you get a draw with the
world champion with black this easy
yeah you you go to your coaches and say
good job guys good good good good good
good
here's a mcdonald's coupon and
yes sir come on
seriously you got to reward good work
was that what victor was giving you
yourself
when you were coaching yeah
okay okay popeyes pop
chicken oh my goodness nice uh
well
does magnus have that look of somebody
who's about to make a draw yes does mvl
have that look no
somehow he's still trying for something
is he actually going to go for 97
no
no i don't think so no
there's no way he goes sorry
no come on mbo
see the problem with knight d7 is look
at the black queen
and how just
boxed in
it is on the a2 square that's a big
problem right exactly yeah
okay and that that beautiful move bishop
d3 knight e4 check
once you see that you gotta go king e8
even if you're planning on knight d7 on
your next turn yeah
yeah
yep
[Music]
they'll call it today perhaps
well very a remarkably successful gambit
and uh you you really want to save a
novelty like that because it's a
gorgeous novelty for a game
like at the sinkfield cup
but
i guess the cat is out of the bag right
now and
people are going to be analyzing that
game for some time to come let's just
and that's
that's a big question right i mean you
have this ridiculous novelty d5 right
right and it's pretty good it definitely
feels like it's pretty good and probably
it works in classical chess as well do
you want to spend it on a rapid game or
a blitz game or a blitz game why
wouldn't you wait for a classical game
because you know this the players are
looking for this uh queen d2 and b3 uh
idea right there's this g6 line which
goes into very very complicated
territory a theory that lasts 25 moves
but if you come as early as move
what was that move um
six d5 i mean if you can get out of
theory with the novelty at move six
that's uh that's a bomb right there so
i'm 100 sure if if you want to spend it
on a rapid uh game
okay
i have a different philosophy
uh my philosophy was was
always that i prepared a lot of
novelties
i didn't always get a chance to play
them though i mean my opponents what was
even worse is like gary was especially
i want to say sensitive to opening
theory and
it was sort of like when i had prepared
something it was like other people got a
chance to play it first
it was very very very frustrating
shaq definitely better and in this case
he's really ready
uh once
again to play rook take c6 a move like
queen d3
queen drops back to e3
is just the end game that even if you
take this pawn i want to play rook
versus knight i can go rook c5 rook a5
uh
you you you have
on a material scale you're doing okay
but actually the rook will dominate the
night very very overnight easily yeah so
that's uh good for
let let's jump to zagreb and alejandra
thank you guys we're here with the world
champion dominant player for over a
decade magnus welcome to the studio tell
us about today's game today d5 seemed to
shock you but you responded well
yeah i don't i don't know i probably
should have should have known that move
when he went five e6 uh i mean i thought
that was a bit of a strange move earlier
if he's gonna go knight f6 so i
figured he was going to go d5 then i
thought man maybe it's not so good
and then
yeah i'd actually kind of
missed his reply in in the game um
it hadn't replied exactly no um 11
knight f6 i just um i just missed
because the queen was was on f6 in the
other lines so the fact that the the
knight would uh
would appear on f6 also where it's not
really protect protecting its its king
was a bit
uh was a bit surprising but fortunately
for me it's um
yeah it's still a it's still a draw aft
after after that which i think was uh
was a pretty uh pretty fair result
overall so that f6 caught you a little
bit but by surprise what were you
expecting
i didn't know what to expect really like
i think when you're encountered with uh
with a surprise in the opening where the
position is super sharp you don't think
you have a lot of expectations you just
try and
try and
hold on somehow and um yeah
some sometimes you can even get a game
but this is normally what happens that
it just turns into some kind of force
draw
magnus we have to ask the big news came
out today you're not defending your
world title does it feel
lighter how do you feel no it's okay i
mean i've been in this mindset now for
uh for over a year so obviously it's uh
um
when it's when it's official it feels
feels a bit weird but i'm i'm fine with
that i'll um continue to to play a bunch
and then
try and uh
you know
just do as well as i can tell us a
little bit how what this means to you as
a player will you be as competitive are
you still trying to get to new heights
or are you slowing down a bit
no i mean i think for a few years now i
haven't been as competitive as i as i
used to be but i still want to play
chess and i still want to do
do well
it's just
i'm i mean i don't
i'm perhaps not quite as you know
i don't have the the same
the same quite the same drive but that's
that doesn't mean i'm going to play a
lot worse no absolutely you're still
dominant in showing great chess tell us
a little bit what this means to you as a
person will you be dedicating time to
other activities
um we'll see i i have
some some ideas don't know if what
they'll
what they'll come to really um otherwise
you know i still love playing chess so
i'm gonna do that a bunch and i have to
ask you the world championship match
won't have you do you think that the
value of it goes down without having the
world champion defend and the best
player
uh yeah i guess so but that's not really
that's not really my my problem oh
absolutely thank you magnus we have
plenty of chess ahead for you guys back
to the studio
thank you alejandro and thank you for
your questions
it had to be asked it had to be asked
magnus
he's aware of the gravity
of the situation because
uh the world of chess
speaking for ourselves would mourn
very much so uh magnus's absence at the
board it was
it was an extraordinary period in chess
where we had such a dominant world
champion who was
first in classical chess rapid and blitz
and oftentimes
had a triple title
and to step back from the
crown jewel of the world of chess the
classical chess
title is
a loss for the chess world yeah
absolutely i just once again a random
thought
when
partially i've joined this you know this
movement myself we were complaining that
a lot of people did complain especially
after the caruana match happened like 12
draws and something had to be changed
for the world championship match to be
more interesting and what we
complainers would do would look for a
better challenger
like detroiting magnus was never an
option i mean it would not cross my mind
at all right so i'm still in in sort of
disbelief so at least he said he'll be
playing chassis yes and not like bobby
fischer simply withdrawing from chess
but actually uh and by the way we'll be
coming to miami
for the melt water championship as well
as to the sinkville cup so he's
definitely keeping uh
his
you know high level agenda where he's
playing a lot of games
and uh
well we're still internalizing the whole
thing i just want to turn our attention
yes sir uh
from youtube uh does carlson not playing
for the world champion feel
reminiscent of fisher not playing or
does it feel completely different
both
the weird part is it feels very very
reminiscent the
the other weird part is absolutely
different is
bobby
quit
stopped completely
he didn't play the world championship
and
really wasn't heard from again
magnus
is going to be a very active player as
he just expressed it himself
so
it's
different
yeah
the way i see it is just from a branding
perspective it feels reminiscent but
from an actual chess perspective bobby
never defended his title right right
magnus stayed at the top for uh it's
been already nine years almost a decade
right so there's definitely different
periods also magnus uh managed to push
chess to new heights let's be honest uh
such a dominant champion he brought new
initiatives into the game so he's
definitely been very active as a chess
player as a champion as a promoter as
well and it does seem like he wants to
maintain those titles he still wants to
push his uh tour as well be the promoter
that he definitely enjoys uh being as
well as a big competitor he said that
his 2 900 rating uh a goal is not
changing anytime soon he is still
gunning for that one so i don't think
we've seen the last of magnus that's for
sure he's still going to maintain his
competitiveness his spirit that brought
him uh to uh well to the mountaintop
no question about it he achieved
extraordinary heights especially in his
home country of norway i mean
single-handedly put chess on the map
norway the fantastic
sports mad country where winter olympic
sports is considered and they're they're
actually
great gold medalist and suddenly
chess was on public television and
people were really
geared
i think for a lot of norwegian
children they're going to be very
unhappy i've been to norway a couple of
times and i've seen all of these kids
with their norwegian flags and their
face painted and then suddenly they've
got chess pieces in their hand they're
asking for autograph
but it's amazing it's uh it's still a
quite a blow for us we're we're we're
settling with it and we'll be asking
more quiz questions to magnus but in the
meanwhile what's what do we think about
the shack
game
he gave up the c6 pawn for what
what did he get what shag snap he got a
couple of checks
well
yeah
one and then jan is thinking but after
queen d1 where the king's running are
you planning on running to h3 yeah isn't
that ironic so first he went for a
perpetual check missing that king hides
on g1 right no
but he was calculating or kind of
expecting the king to run to h3 now he
gives up the second pawn or whatever he
he given in exchange went for the
perpetual now he goes for a perpetual
the king runs through
so he wasn't allowed yet yeah
back then but it's almost some kind of a
double punishment yeah like you got it
wrong the first time and now you're
going to find it you guys have tried
everything yeah
i mean not only that but you're the one
getting checkmated right yeah absolutely
exactly exactly the moment the checks
stop rook c8 is yeah and rook h8 and
suddenly the king gets flushed there's
actually a very nice checkmate if you
take on b2 for example rook to c8 maybe
we can show that on the board yes
king h7 rook h8
king g6 rook g8 back
and now if you go to h5 then i can go g4
oh that's not a checkmate no queen h2
this is where christian says and now the
genius oh
yeah it was actually i was actually a
little bit puzzled
what is the checkmate
i was really very very quiet the way you
were waiting for
wait a second can you do it in a
different order king h5 girl queen e1
would it be i mean if this song it would
be there's no one
but that's about it yeah you have one
check but king g1 and then g4 was got to
be that's it right yeah that looks very
nice
that's it yeah good idea wrong execution
you say but christian inspired yeah
teamwork
the two of you make a formidable player
[Laughter]
but yes that's a very very nice check
made similar to that as the whole idea
is if you don't take on
b2 but if you do
uh continue was
the king ends up on h3
where it's really ready to deliver the
mate uh as you've described it with g4
already uh this looks
sorry for
your
brilliant
[Laughter]
you just understand you suck
nice try but but we like the new blood
right christian
absolutely absolutely what have you been
uh keeping your eye on i was looking at
pretty much all the games and trying to
see where we stand not as many things
have been happening except this one the
game between ferruja and a struggling
vessel in topalov and this is where we
stand right now one pawn to the good for
ali reza still we do have the opposite
car bishops on the board so that could
potentially uh help black in his quest
to maintain or find
the elusive equality right now
nevertheless it does feel like alireza
is on the brink of potentially breaking
through you still have some problems in
your structure as black and only three
minutes for vaseline and 17 minutes for
ali reza huge time uh difference in this
one maybe we can pan to that game with
the cameras and see the expression of
vaseline top hall of right now by the
way too that uh purple violet jacket
reminds me of the joker almost yeah yeah
it's a very v and
vessel is like what am i doing
uh he started with two losses by the way
so this would basically be the third one
terrible i wanted to turn our attention
while we admire vessel and jacket to the
game of lanier uh versus ivan saric
because
you may be early here in st louis but i
can count two rooks
and i can count one rook for lanier uh
what's going on uh he did not lose the
rook i can tell you that he's a
sacrifice yeah
and his idea is
um
wow there's your answer bishop a4 bishop
a4 seriously that did not
oh he's covering e8 yeah
oh isn't that beautiful so if the queen
goes away yes it's a couple of checks
and the age file with the rook
right or or it's yeah it's just i can
then check on each step yes because
the this is the important part yeah the
hiding
bolt
the e8 square has been magically covered
with a gain of tempo so that forces you
to take yeah
queen to c7 right now those checks do
not lead anywhere so what about rook to
f7 there's a d1 why is this that bad
yeah and then you go to
f7 and it's
uh what
um
on the board
is it this is remarkable can i actually
go check on h1 okay give up the attack
on the bishop king g8 is the only queen
e5 or one still queen e5 right now rook
g7 do you have wow
it's a perpetual right no i'm winning uh
[Laughter]
h7 i've got queen
no you've got queen d1 no no wait a
minute so
i still go rook g7 queen e6 rook f7 how
how do you check with me
i was going to take the g disappears
yeah it just shows yeah i think so if if
you
block
my mating thread with rook g7 i was
going to check right and i was going to
check you again and then you have g6 at
the end
and by the way topalov resigned guys wow
yeah that would win that would win uh
sorry let me just check uh
but what happened to this is a disaster
it did it just like completely fell
apart the the damn collapse and burst
and everything else i want to go back
again to the game that we're just
following because this is yeah this is
exciting
guys if this works for white it's really
a remarkable conception so rook to f6 to
h1 is on the board
now you have to go king g8 is absolutely
false otherwise this check is
devastating so king to g8
yeah and then once again by the way how
devastating is that check again
well okay 725 bishop f6 how how bad is
that how bad is that bishop f6 okay
captures
your fields at least you can take on d5
right i could take on d5 i'm a little
bit more afraid of
some kind of second queen d8 or queen b
right
but he always going to have rook f8 rook
f7 yes so we will have to settle in d5
by the way we have king g825 on the
board
wow and by the way
the clock times because lanier is
playing this combination 14 minutes for
lanier only five minutes for saric
right and
boy for yvonne i mean he's certainly
been in a roller coaster ride these
first two games
and then suddenly you know he's a rook
ahead and
uh lanier is attacking him like a genius
okay what about this okay what about
rook two h7 that was through h7 yeah i
think we were forced to come to
come to terms with but then i was afraid
i was losing the g pawn with check
queen d1 no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
yeah you can't really take on h7 that's
the problem
correct can you can you take on d5
though and make it yes try to now i
cover d1 but now i go king g7 right and
this is where you lose this is
no
and there is no check there's no queen
eight my queen is there queen e8 is it
would have been yeah it would have been
that was where i pick up the g pawn also
with check oh my goodness
so then i have to go back yeah we can
return back so pretend that we won a d5
pawn for free but now would you believe
there is no problem no progress
that is because i had a hard time
believing i have a hard time believing
that white country well actually now you
might be worried right i have to be be
careful not to you have to stay on d5 i
think mm-hmm
wow
so evan is
so sorry seven is not a very clear yeah
he has to find this rook h7 otherwise
he's he's stopped
so this is the current position and yeah
and rook h sevens
and look at his uh i mean i think he's a
disbelief
he was
lost
and he he
i miss bishop a4 and you know i'm
surrounded with all of this talented
grand masters and
his he's incredulous about his situation
right now totally he thinks he's lost
lanier has been blitzing out his moves
right
showed confidence up to this point and
basically just
is willing his way into a victory in
this one if he doesn't find rook to h7
and he might not just because of the
fact that he thinks the assessment is
that he's lost right now and i won't be
surprised if lanier is thinking that
he's winning
very likely you know yes it's very
likely
like this is energy the confidence thing
yeah i mean if you see that the opponent
got the defense somehow you turn to
transition this sense and he even though
he's very stone-faced right now you see
he's not uh showing any
any signs yeah but but sorry just look
at him yeah he's clearly
right
and look to age seven no will he find it
it it so often times happens in chess
this double blindness
or this
uh transference if you will my
confidence has transferred across the
board
to
depress my opponent absolutely and he
misses
the defense
rook h7
by the way and he found it and instantly
queen takes d5 yeah he got it all
figured out and then what did we say
king king
f-a
only moves
but
h7 what are we talking about
what we were doing
king g7
yeah because queen d1 is protected king
to f8 uh comes when you put the queen on
e6 e that's right five or queen e6 yeah
yeah that's right so that i still have
queen to d1 at the end correct
so with the
deep
all right but let's figure out where
texas is king to h8 work right now
or is king to ga the only king to g7 the
only move
kh8 seems to work
king
king h8 you still have queen to d4 but
that doesn't change anything king to g7
is on board
okay that's the more
natural move
to my eyes than king h8
all right linear you blissed out your
music more than a perpetual
that's what show me the goods yeah yeah
right our inquiring minds want to know
uh
and maybe he realizes also that
this might be his escape just
wait a second shouldn't we be doubting
our
face reading right he's right
he looked like he felt doomed and you
know was cursing himself and then all of
a sudden he plays two
now rook to e1 you cannot prolong the
game like that king to f8 and you're
probably just going to be a p star right
is that so sure
you want king i don't have queen e8 and
i have 28 i'm boxing myself in and it
feels like that yeah
more or less fine
wow
so there's actually no way for you to
continue because it's it's it's hard to
believe that a moment ago we had this
situation where we had a queen
on the seventh rank
we had a rook hitting the bishop and
then the rook voluntarily moved away
and we jumped to the current position
and we start thinking that the rook
would come back to e1
after voluntarily moving away not so
long ago yeah yes since we are back to
this please can we can we go a couple of
moves back because we had a question
what happens to king g7 and apparently
i've figured this one out remember so
when rook h1 no no when rook h1 was
first played and we said okay it's not
clear how to beat king g7 but yeah he is
now so king g7 queen e5 check we we look
at the right and after bishop f6 you do
not take you go queen b8 you go queen b8
at once and the point is like queen h8
is still a deadly threat
rook f8 and this is the moment you take
the bishop black has no
no response yeah no no piece to take on
f6 yeah that's a beautiful trick it
really really is oh my goodness
thank you for that uh well that is
really
outstanding yeah i think we're just
gonna see i think we're gonna see a
perpetual
actually to ivan i mean defending this
one with your opponent
almost 2800 blitzing out his moves like
this with confidence exactly it's
impressive yeah
especially when he was showing signs
that he's in distress right and that's
when you're at your most uh
vulnerable
queen to
e5 so now he's changing the setup just a
little bit
yeah he still has it right uh king of
wait king knocking f8 wait a minute king
of fate well maybe he's kind of fine
with king of fate queen f4 check and
then
no no but king king of fate you have
queen b8
queen oh yeah queen b8 king justin
yeah yeah that's the reason you're right
so so he he's still a per
always has a perpetual yeah
and i think that actually maybe forces
it no but then you also have to contend
with queen takes f4 maybe you don't want
to do that just go king g8
don't allow him to take on f4
because then even if you go to e8 and he
goes for king to f8 he goes for kingdom
f8 wow yeah but that that is what i was
thinking so now if we can pick up one
more pawn with a check and then return
to this position right yes slowly slowly
but then you don't have the perpetual
maybe finally
one yeah no but maybe
king g8 don't i have no more perpetual
for you yeah you're right
and rookie one it's uh it's a tricky
business you want to get that one for a
piece that's not what you wanted when
you entered
this
so king f8 may be a nice little trap
cheapo uh
by evon as he tries to lure his opponent
into overreaching with queen takes f4
king g8
and just let's just
uh take a gander yeah
game still long
like okay nepo is uh is down to his last
trump card he has just played the move
g4 check
uh by the way king takes g4 looks like
the absolutely the only move
can you take g4 and
only but good enough
only but good enough queen takes
and then the king hides back or even the
kite yeah much better
much better the very frustrating h3
square yeah right
uh and what does h5 check
h5
now do i have to go back three perhaps
and
a draw a very
uh
creative game i wanted to say that was a
very easy little lear dropped to rook
then he was a piece down then he refused
to recapture it there was mates on both
sides of the board queen d1
for ivon and
and nepo designed
has lost
yep
but well for shaq again another one of
those really
roller coaster
days uh
by the way this is the first time i've
seen nepal lose a game
in a while in a long while
i mean it certainly it didn't happen
during the candidates we all know that
and we have one remaining game that is
the
tournament leader yeah
the dutch fans are screaming and
gnashing their teeth and angst
and what do we have uh well that's a
pretty powerful pawn
uh passer by white on the d6 square yeah
but after 95 somehow it doesn't look
it doesn't look
as menacing as
some people want it to be pawn takes
back perhaps
pawn takes
yeah that's the question what you take
it with probably with the pawn right
yeah if you take with the knight i'm
thinking queen b6 with the idea of queen
season 7 will be might hurt your
feelings so
here
the the knight stands ready to make a
blockade
and that's important also by the way
jordan's king is
remarkably safe from any
uh
wayward interferences
but it has to be white to be preferred
sure
but give me uh like what if i go queen
b6 now i have this little trick if you
go rook to d8 i even in this position
have the move queen to c7 right oops
that was a finger failure of my
apologies slight trick in the position
oh that's a nice one if you take take
and probably if you go rook to c8 after
bishop e5 rook d7 you might be hurting
in that end game
um and if you don't if you take my rook
then king to h2n there's no it's not the
pawn
so queen b6 still problems for jordan to
solve
but
my
temptation would be to play rook and
knight g6 was knight g6 g6
in order to defend from f8 blockade from
methane uh yeah that's can't say i'm a
big fan of this movie obviously yeah
what to believe
that is
that's strange if you were going to play
for knight f8
you would have
rather started with knight f8 right so
can i try to uh get the rook to the a
file after knight g6 maybe rook to a1
makes a lot of sense right he did not he
played queen to c7 and knight to f8 is
on the board
queen to c7 knight f8 on the board
okay well this is
the
i'm not going to say the ideal but uh
certainly uh you're blockading
the pawn's not going to c7 and it's not
going to d7 what has the times by the
way very hard for me seven minutes for
jordan only two minutes and 40 seconds
okay one of the things that uh i do
really
respect about wesley is that
it's the consistency of his moves
so many times we just see wesley just
playing
a lot a lot a lot of just
good moves he very very rarely
makes any egregious error i want to say
and it seems like uh so far up to this
point uh after three rounds half of the
games have been decisive this is just
remarkable
and you might be wondering why after two
rounds van forest has four points and
wesley two of them well because we score
a rapid differently than blitz we give
two points for a victory in rapid and
one point for a draw in blitz which is
going to become day four and day five
that's when we're going to return to the
classical scoring format exactly we do
have uh rook c8 on the board and
you almost think to yourself
is it really a threat to take my queen
you know like sometimes wesley thinks so
and wesley uh said yeah well i mean
actually there is a threat this was what
i was thinking that if we could get the
rook behind the pawn
can i at least play c5 and stop ideas of
queen h5 it wasn't
was this absolutely certain queen takes
knight takes
rook to d7
i guess you just
no yeah rook d8
but do i have to go rook to d8 or can i
even go knight to e5 already at that
point
yeah maybe maybe not because you have
rook c7 oh yeah no
yeah
the the worst i could do is win a pawn
right so these and now c5 perhaps is an
absolute must
yes
to cover that rank and also to remind
white that yes your pawn is further
advanced but yeah i do have
one of the things that amateurs should
always realize well your worst blockader
is your queen
your basketball cater actually is a
knight because the night oftentimes
blockades especially upon
you know on the fifth rank the knight
stands in front of the pawn and it
attacks
uh square so uh
c5 well this is going for it good
queen e6 and knight d7 is also
highly recommended in such positions to
trade
like that is rook to b7 followed by
queen to a7 just feels a little bit off
d7 if you go queen to e6 knight d7 but
he won c5 he won c5 c5 and queen a6
instantly queen a6
instantaneously so what does he want
uh as we watch this game we're going to
just turn to zagreb as we have alejandro
with lanier dominguez
we're here with a top theoretician
linear dominguez that was a crazy draw
you just had
how does it feel you won a brilliancy
prize with this variation already and
you decided to go into it again
yeah i mean it's obviously very
tricky line for black i knew it was a
draw but i thought that in rapid chess
and
it's kind of hard to to find all the
moves or even even if you know them
which you're supposed to know but still
you have to remember and it's not so
simple but he
i mean he did all right and i think uh
yeah there was nothing to do yeah he
played this move queen e8 which was
definitely uh the improvement from your
game of course against maxima sherlock
at the same field cup but you still kept
some pressure yeah i mean after rook d1
of course is the logical move and then
uh yeah black has to go rook c7 and it
looks very
i mean dangerous for black because you
gotta move the bishop and i'm opening
the h file
but uh yeah it's just move per move here
this d5 and queen c6 i think it's very
precise i think queen a8 is also
probably fine but but d5 and and queen
e5 and then i think the critical moment
what was after
hd fg rook h7 the wreckage was great i
was on the playing hall and you went for
your rook took on h7 your opponent
seemed a bit surprised and this move
bishop a4 how did you even come up with
this idea uh yeah i mean i thought that
uh
it's possible but uh
black's moves black's moves after that
are not that difficult i mean rook f7
and so it's the only move but it's such
an obvious move so i wasn't sure if uh
if i should go for this or or to play uh
instead of bishop a4 rook h1 and rook h6
i believe it's also
objectively equal and now bishop f6 is
the correct move not such a simple move
but black doesn't have many moves anyway
and after df6 rook f6 i didn't really
see
how i'm playing for a win here i thought
that potentially this could be of course
tricky for me so i went for the other
line which uh i mean i i saw it was just
a draw absolutely topsy-turvy day today
had a tough one in round two how do you
feel at the end of today yeah i mean
it's uh i mean wasn't the best day in
the world for me but uh it's the first
day so
main thing was just to to
get into and to practice a little bit
and hopefully
tomorrow will be better linear dominguez
looking for those brilliancy prices well
let's see what happens in the last game
remaining in today's round back to the
studio alejandro if you may ask lanier
for a quick
question about the whole magnus and how
he feels as an international grand
master world class player magnus
stepping down from the world
championship match oh
we wanted to ask you as well we had big
news today
magnus carlsen won't be defending his
world championship title your thoughts
yeah i mean initially i thought it's uh
that's not really going to happen but
yeah it's it's for real so
i guess uh
he has his reasons uh it's very
interesting because he seems to do what
nobody else does
so
yeah in a way i think
i can understand that the pressure of
defending the the title when there is a
possibility obviously that you can lose
takes a lot of
energy and it's stressful and all that
and he yeah he just wants to
to play without pressure just to play
tournaments so i can
i can see that i mean it's uh
obviously
uh strange in the sense that if you're
the best player in the world you you you
should play normally and and and and
you have many things to achieve like
legacy and stuff like that but yeah i
guess it's his decision and uh
it's an interesting one seems like it
comes to as a shock to you
yeah well i
at some point i mean at the beginning i
thought it's just uh he's uh
just kidding a bit i mean he was maybe
messing with the other players and the
candidates because psychologically it
also put some pressure on some people
but then i realized that maybe he's uh
is for real so it's uh yeah it's an
interesting decision absolutely and
today well confirmation for real magnus
carlsen will not be defending well thank
you lanier and good luck the rest of the
tournament thank you thank you lanier i
always interesting to hear the
perspectives of the players and
they're right there i mean you know
there's the world champion saying guys
lots of luck
but we've got a tournament the grand
chess tour it's ongoing and we've got a
game
uh our tournament leader jordan van
forest on the right with the black
pieces
uh has won his first two games and but
guys how do we feel about the position
right now after this move to b8 yeah i
have a big threat rook to b2 you cannot
touch the knight right
you don't have time to do that you have
to go queen to d2 but now i can defend
from the side rook to b7 i have
everything protected and i have a pawn
up precisely
he just snapped he just spawned swindled
uh
wesley saw right now rather wesley saw
swindled himself amazing at some point
yeah but
that's way better that's unexpectedly
five knight to e5 rook b7 was crying
isn't it isn't it like pushing it too
far this 95 thing knight e5 i'll wait a
second but you cannot take because it's
a rook be one intimate
but by the way even that is not very
clear right right to be one i have king
2f2 absolutely absolutely but there's
also there's also this d7
uh
which
normally speaking you don't let the oh
rook e7 came that's the times because
i'm not really too sure wesley is like
down to his one minute and thirty seven
seconds against one minute and 50 for
jordan
this is uh this is where nerves
plays a
crucial role uh
the first thing i look at is checks
right because you almost thinking if you
can get the king to go to h2 you've got
another check and maybe rook to b2
uh what what's your need your reaction
to the queen b1 check doesn't it look
does it just work
yeah well i don't think it works right
why
uh
and then rook to e2
queen b one check so knight to f3 right
take take and then wrote the beat
and you wanna
rook to e2
and as we are keeping this
our eyes on this one we're going to jump
back to zagreb and alejandro with napo
we're here with the man that crushed the
candidates jane
not the best day for you but on the
other hand huge news
what are your feelings now that you're
going to be playing ding loretta instead
of magnus carlsen
yeah quite some news uh you know i'm
not privileged not supposed to speak you
know on behalf of the chess community
yes i'll just
speak on behalf of myself it
yeah personally for me was of course
quite disappointing
and just quite sad and uh
it's not about like the human decision
it's completely understandable and of
course i respect it uh because first of
all uh
uh
me like and magnus like we have some
quite good relationships and we know
each other like for i would say 20 years
or something
so
i
can imagine it was quite a painful
decision for him as well
but i also feel like maybe maybe he felt
himself more or less like i would say
hostage of this whole situation yes so
he
[Music]
probably yes he obliged to
supposedly he obliged to to defend the
title every time and uh perhaps it's
it's a huge pressure yes out of my uh
quite small comparing to him experience
of the title matches it's uh it could be
not not great but uh i mean also like
the candidates yeah despite the result
it's very tough
so
of course uh it's quite disappointing
for me but uh also i guess it could be
you know quite some harm which could be
down to the chest by this decision but i
mean once again i'm
i'm not in position to to judge
and um
i must say that magnus was is and
probably will be
uh one of the greatest chess ambassadors
uh you know regardless his decision
talk to us a little bit about the
upcoming match i mean you're playing a
completely different player you're not
going to be playing the number one
player in the world in your personal
opinion does it host does it hold the
same value
well i think so because
it's
more or less you know it's it's the same
yeah it's uh it's a title match
and uh
once again i have as i have said before
for many times uh you know i relate
things chess quality is like quite high
uh
i wouldn't say like he's uh like
uh anything quicker like overall in
chess wise than magnus okay magnus is
a tremendous sportsman and uh this uh
however makes um
makes a difference but uh yeah just wise
dink is just completely outstanding
player
absolutely it's gonna be a tough match
as we see there your match against
dingley reigns scheduled for next year
it's gonna be a tough one we wish you
the best of luck on this tournament and
of course on the match thank you thank
you guys back to the studio one game
remaining thank you uh jan for
sharing your thoughts uh again it's just
such a big day this is international
chess day the irony
mirror is that on this day of days uh
uh one of the greatest most dominant
world champions ever
uh announces that he's not going to
defend his title
yeah
he's not retiring he's not
that's very important right it's not the
situation that we had with bobby fischer
completely disappearing exactly we have
a completely different story he's still
within the chess world but it does
diminish the
uh prestige of the world championship
title in my opinion nepo said that no i
i think it kind of does it does a quick
question about the game underway wesley
so up a rook but
uh
is there
is there a way that he can dance his way
out of a perpetual
mirror king d3 for example
but i think black has to be very careful
giving those checks so let's go behind
let's go from f1 basically i'm just
trying to take advantage of the fact
that i don't think you can go to d5
at any time oh yeah so
check
i don't want to allow you to go to b k
e4 okay
so if you go to b5 then i'm in trouble
king fall but how are you going between
that four queen full back yeah yeah yeah
he did go
hold on king to c3 is on to c3 but now
queen to c1 doesn't that force a draw
oh you can still go to c4 i guess
well you've got queen to be fortunate
before it's going to be and again i
can't go to d5
yeah but queen b4 and queen king they
tricking b queen b1 exactly perhaps keep
again
in the zone yes that is
that's a very tricky that's giant petrol
that is geometry five and c5 pawns
nice oh that's beautiful
and if you go to e2 i go to e4
wow
it's a way to say but the url is down to
like what seconds literally five seconds
guys no in three seconds it's going to
see two points to lose must lose right
yeah now he lets the king go in escapes
it flees he missed queen v five seconds
on the clock four seconds three and he
plays c4 with two seconds now
this is over he's like
he is capitulated here with uh
these last few moves oh what a turn of
events guys he was so close queen before
geometry he was so close oh my word
well i must say there's probably
numerous ways to win it
queen c7 threatening g7 threatening the
pawn on c4 threatening the pawn on e5
this is this is it also defending the
the queen that's so important yeah and
the other queen and the rook are
defending yeah queen takes g2 was not a
happy move
no
no
simply take on e5 yeah queen e5 queen e5
looks the best so that you can
you can check on you have one more f5
and then it's a meeting that
has to resign
and wesley again
the wesley does his thing
he starts the event with two blacks in a
row he makes awkward tricky but draws
and
he wins his white game so does that mean
that we have a log jam at the top well
let's take a look at our current
standings
uh
yes listen to
the old wise man on the council
omnipresent
chuckle
okay probe christian as uh
well i think we've had a very very
decisive
number of games i
i'm probably guessing 50 or more and the
games have been decisive
as ali
raza
miro a very nice day at the office for
us
yeah of course i mean since you picked
alireza
you can't be happier look but look at
that trailing pack magnus carlson wesley
slow mvl jordan van porris all on four
points that that's a gang of uh wolves
right there pack of wolves
and uh shaq
so strange fortunes or
misfortunes yeah the only one on 50
right and he had like all three results
yeah it was possible
our challenger our challenger who looked
invulnerable during the candidates
sitting on minus one
we also surprised lanier minus one ivan
saric minus one and vessel and topalov
just a very very bad day the wheels
came off
uh for him too
and let's uh refresh our schedule uh
yeah so today same same time same place
three more rapid games rounds four to
six yeah tomorrow on friday yeah
same's gonna be and then weekend it's
blitz we can do splits and that's yeah
that's gonna be a lot of fun once again
yeah 18 rounds of double round robin
blitz and christian
uh
your thoughts as we wait for wesley so
to show up and uh get interviewed i mean
i have to say this uh first of all has
been a historic day uh for the simple
fact that magnus decided not to defend
the title so that's the big news of the
day but of course the tournament has
been progressing and a lot of stories
are developing and one in particular
that i'm having my eyes on is your pick
uh yasser ali reza ali reza there's been
a lot of pressure on him since he
qualified the candidates he could have
been the youngest um challenger he could
have been the youngest world champion if
he would have went on and uh won against
magnus later on but he did none of that
there was a lot of pressure right now
he's relieved right he
did lose he did not play in the while in
the candidates but he has so many years
ahead of himself so we could be seeing a
surging alireza with less pressure right
now this is what i'm looking at uh as
you can see only 19 years of age it's
not the the correct number right there
not 80 yeah it's already 19 but here is
just
impressive in this tournament up to this
point
he did definitely and again 19 uh i
remember him celebrating his birthday
during the candidates
uh
boy i just must say i i just feeling
this
overwhelming this sense of uh
you know
magnus
i mean
he has stole all the you know all the
[ __ ]
no questions
when we
specifically corrected that magnus is
not retiring but was bobby retiring i
don't think he was right he said he will
not
yeah at the time he
he said
very very clearly that bobby
uh wanted to be a very active world
champion that he wouldn't sit on his
title
that he was anxious to make money
and raise the prestige of chess
and as it turned out he ended up getting
involved in all kinds of lawsuits that
were related to iceland especially with
chester fox
and the videos uh the video writes
to the games that chester fox sued him
and then he sued
time magazine for writing a book bobby
fisher versus the rest of the world by
brad derrick
and he just
imploded
all of these lawsuits uh got the best of
bobby and it was just uh
very sad
magnus is a completely different uh
boat he he magnus really
we were told at least during madrid
that magnus had met with arkady uh
dorkovich the
president of the fidei that they had
good discussions and magnus presented
his ideas of what he wanted
for the world championship and
it supposedly was going well
but let's turn to zagreb and some final
thoughts with alejandro and
anastasia
what an exciting day of chess we had in
international chess day tons of thrills
and spills alareza the clear leader of
day one despite so many victories by
different players nasty are your
thoughts um my thoughts i think first of
all that today we had really big news
magnus carson said that he's not going
to play the match i think at least both
two players were affected by those news
i mean magnus didn't play i think him
the the way he usually plays i think
also yanni pomeshi was also affected as
well as others and also i must admit
that the atmosphere still was really
really great in the plane when you had
lots of spectators i mean it was really
a holiday chess
real chess international day here in
zagreb yeah absolutely the players were
just
surrounded by fans every time they left
the stage there were so many people so
many children looking for their
autographs it was great to see i know
the players love seeing the spectators
be their present in their games today
was a wonderful day for chess i thought
the games were spectacular even the last
one that we finished there between
wesley so and jordan for us was such a
fight i can't wait for the rest of the
event yeah that was really great day we
heard the plots of spectators as well
you can also follow us in the social
media and see some nice stories in
instagram and follow the action all the
time
with us well we're signing off here from
the zagreb tomorrow will be day two of
the rapid
thank you anastasia thank you alejandro
don't get mobbed by the crowds alejandro
be careful don't give up your autograph
too easily
and as we sign off we want to thank you
once again for joining us
you're a wonderful big saint louis
welcome to you and we will see you
tomorrow and we will see you all thanks
very much tomorrow what a warm welcome
yes thank you
[Music]
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st
louis chess club any reproduction or
distribution of this content without the
express written consent of the st louis
chess club is prohibited
you